Five four,
three.
I was good that day,
but then the next day like oh live and we're live herb dean.
How are you sir?
I'm good.
How about yourself?
So glad we finally doing this.
You and I have talked about doing a podcast for the last like three years.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm glad to be on it.
Yeah,
I ain't got what you talk to you for a little bit.
I think in,
I've said this before,
you have the hardest job in the sport other than the fighters does.
The fighters,
obviously they have the hardest job.
You have the second hardest job referees,
the second hardest job in the sport.
It's a fucking hard job.
You have so much responsibility.
Yeah,
I think you have a really hard job.
I think the talk,
how long do you talk more?
It's just hours.
Six hours,
six hours in.
Then sometimes there's not always something interesting to talk about and a or
sometimes yet,
so I think it's amazing to be able to talk about that.
It's not that easy.
It's not that hard.
Rather it's pretty easy.
I mean,
it's just a bunch of stuff's happening and you're calling it,
and I'm,
I'm a blabber mouth so I can't shut the fuck up anyway.
So if there's spots where this,
it's not that interesting.
I find something interesting to say,
but it's not that it's,
you know,
in terms of like what,
what's happening is happening.
You know what I mean?
The guys getting hit it guys getting choked.
There's a lot of crazy action going on and it's really pretty easy if you're a
lifelong fan of martial arts,
like I call it,
you know,
as long as you're enthusiastic and you're interested in doing and you know,
you got to treat it with respect,
you've got to treat it for what it is.
You know,
you're trying to entertain people.
You're trying to,
uh,
use the,
your words in the most pleasing way possible.
You know,
you're trying to massage people's ears in a way,
you know,
you're trying to,
you trying to also represent what you're seeing and how special it is because
actually yeah,
I did it a little bit.
Not for real.
Like,
uh,
somehow I do this thing that was for these people,
Black Belt TV and I was with um,
dawn the Dragon Wilson and they're just like old fight and we're supposed to
come and take this old fight.
And that's why I think it's hard because I was horrible at it.
Old fights are harder because you might know what's already happened so you got
to play dumb.
And so it's like almost like you have to be an actor as well as commenting on a
fight.
I think it would be harder to call an old fight.
Yeah.
Because in the back of your head you'd be like,
I'm a big phony.
I know what's happening.
It's already happened.
I think they did that with some of the pride fights.
I sing,
I think some of the pride fights they uh,
they did the commentary after the action cause he might,
do you remember when pride would come on at like three o'clock in the morning
and we wouldn't get it to like a day later or something like that.
I remember one time I was the worst is when when your friends tells you,
cause you,
you,
you wait,
you don't look at the,
I remember I was training,
I think I went and I trained with savant in one time and I don't know if you
know him.
Sure.
Yeah.
And we had been in the car the whole time.
Really?
I was like,
well when I get home and watch pri and then right before he got dropped him off
at his house,
right before I get to the car he goes,
oh Vandelay Silva lost.
Oh Oh.
Or something like that.
He said something like that.
Yeah.
We would have to wait sometimes.
Like there was a couple events where I feel like it was like a week or something
crazy,
wasn't it?
So you had to like stay off the Internet for a week.
Which is,
which is good for me.
You know,
I could do it,
but yeah,
but you got to also avoid all your friends were a little internet fanatics.
They start talking and you're like,
stop.
Stop.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know who won yet.
These days it's so bad.
Like if I go and I do a comedy show on the night of like a big boxing match or
something like that,
like my text messages tell me like,
people start sending me to the,
they,
they can't wait to spoil shit to like,
Damn.
Galop can got robbed.
And I was like,
what?
What happened off?
Fuck.
And then I don't get to just watch it.
I want to just come home and hit the DVR and watch it.
I'll keep the fuck away from the news.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let me get home.
But then all the text messages will get me,
it's almost like I can't even read text messages.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
God dammit.
It's funny big.
You don't enjoy a fight,
even if it's a great fight as much.
If you don't know if you know what happened.
Yeah,
no,
you're not.
No,
you're,
you want to watch it for the first time.
Yeah.
As it is.
Like I heard the gate,
she knocked out Barboza and I was like,
wow,
we didn't shoot that cod.
Oh my God.
Kate.
She's a savage.
He's a savage man.
He's got a special kind of savagery.
There's some,
you know,
like,
I guess it's all judged on a spectrum.
There's some dudes and it just so ferocious.
They're just so willing to lead into battle
into it.
Yeah.
And to engage and yeah,
that guy,
just a gauges.
It's a weird willingness to engage.
I'm all stuck.
Almost fearless willingness to engage it seems like,
like,
yeah.
When and when he's in there getting it,
that's when,
uh,
it seems like he's just at his happiest.
Right?
Yeah.
Crazy.
I wrapped up top like that.
Um,
I have sold,
like,
I refer a lot of fights in,
um,
and Russia.
So a I referee to fight with this guy,
um,
by lie of a Murat by Leia versus Solomon,
a man.
And it was for championship,
uh,
Aca.
Man,
these,
these guys went to war.
He,
um,
he heard him early on and had him,
you know,
almost put out and then he came back by ballet of loss,
but it was his is,
I mean,
as a older than him,
he's over 40,
pushing the pressure and made a really,
uh,
yeah,
but you can,
I saw that energy come out like when he was struggling through the hard times,
you could tell that like,
you know,
some sort of battle joy was on him.
You know what I mean?
He's that Kinda Guy Battle Jato joy,
you know what I mean?
You hear it like,
oh,
he's in it,
you know,
battle joy's real shit.
Yeah.
Right.
Huh.
That'll joy Diego Sanchez is all full of battle droid.
Yeah.
Good example.
It didn't die with the Vikings as
people were experiencing battled
to I to this day.
Oh yeah.
There's my man right there.
It is that he just look it up.
Fucking bodies covered in blood and you know,
and there's,
and happiest,
the happiest they can be.
God Damn,
that dude's face is busted up.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
did you see the bare knuckle fighting having watched the,
any of them?
Yeah.
I watched some exchanges between,
it's just,
it's hard to watch.
It's weird.
I was a big proponent of bare knuckle.
I was like they should fight bare knuckle cause it's ridiculous that you pad up
only your gloves but you don't pat up your elbows,
knees.
But I'm
Jason ninth versus Artem low ball off was a,
it was a weird fight to watch man.
I mean they beat the fuck out of each other.
I heard both came out of it.
Super cut up man.
Like a lifetime's worth of cuts in one fight.
Yeah.
And you,
you saw that.
It's like I think it's going to be a,
it looks like the,
she saw their faces that looks like it's going to be some long healing.
Yeah man.
I mean these guys beat the shit out of each other.
Bare knuckle and it's,
it is kind of weird that you do recognize,
first of all they're not really,
they're bare knuckle but they're not bear risks.
Like look how their hands are all wrapped up to prevent them from breaking.
Which is,
it's interesting.
It shows us how fragile our hands really are.
No,
no,
you gotta do.
And so that's why I,
I didn't really think that a bare knuckle was going to be that I knew,
uh,
that more,
intense.
But when I'm seeing some of these matches,
they are a really intense,
but at the end of the day,
I think the bottom line is still is the most dangerous weapons,
I think.
Where the elbows and knees,
right?
Yeah.
For cuts for sure.
And for damage.
I mean,
none of those needs that Jon Jones had a brand new barrel,
windmills,
elbows,
John,
John hit print it for sure.
Yeah.
No,
John's from the mount position from the top.
He's got some of the most horrific elbows of all time and not from even from the
hat.
From the guard,
right?
Yeah.
From anywhere.
Remember Tito Ortiz never pass card.
Never pass card.
Just beat everybody up from inside of the guard.
Smashed him from,
and he was an expert.
Joe Shillings last fight.
He cut that dude up real bad.
All from inside.
The guard was horrible.
Ground and pound with his elbows.
Yeah.
But I think for the most damage it's like,
I think it's like a wheel kick to the head.
Yeah.
That's the most,
like when you remember when Barboza fought Adam.
Yeah.
That's like the most damage to the wheel kick to the head is,
and that's man that um,
yeah.
Who,
who used to do that?
We'll kick to the head or he just fought,
um,
guy.
He's from Canada.
Oh.
From Canada.
He just fought,
but he didn't do a wheel kick.
He didn't do it.
Um,
what was it he said kid,
everybody would have spinning back kick and he's a UFC guy or it's for a short
dick guy.
Is it make Dessie John Mick?
Does he?
Yeah.
Mack does.
He's a taekwondo guy.
How many people?
He cut a couple of people with spinning back kick around probably.
I mean,
he's caught people with a lot of stuff.
He's got a full kicking arsenal.
But yeah,
originally I went to taekwondo background.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's amazing that you're seeing all these different styles that it's still,
even all these years in,
there's all these different styles of fighting like coke.
They're completely different.
You've got like the Ben aspirins style still just grab a hold of him.
You just superior wrestling,
beat his ass.
And then you got style vendor stocked full on,
super technical striker tricking.
You set traps,
you know,
like as a person who loves striking,
like,
uh,
it's a,
it's an interesting time,
you know,
there's so much variety.
There's so much shit going on.
And it's so funny because so many things come back and they go back and forth
and there's all these things that people are telling you,
you're not supposed to do this or this isn't going to work.
And then someone comes up and shuts it all down to the end.
Now this is going to work.
And so it's,
it's,
so,
it's always so exciting.
How about that Russian dude?
What is his name?
The guy that only neck who oh yeah.
With the fucking,
he gets people to [inaudible] from the mount.
Your mounting him and he kills you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
all the time,
right?
Yeah.
Zika,
what amount?
He gets it from,
from your guard.
He's in your garden,
Ezekiel's you.
And uh,
he's,
yeah,
and that's exactly the guy.
Like he's that guy who,
who,
uh,
everybody else that is a crazy grip.
The weight does it.
You can see how tight it is.
That is amazing that he does,
he has gripped like,
no,
cause he,
I mean he,
uh,
he does scarf,
chokes the scarf,
whole chokes the people he's done.
It took quite a few and I seen he laces it up a little different.
I think he did want to and uh,
but he,
he does stuff that nobody else does.
Carful chokes are legit.
You gotta remember like,
um,
Josh Barnett tapped out.
Dean lister with Chuck.
He,
but he,
I think he's done to people with that.
Right?
He's the,
did that one.
He did one guy in the UFC with it and,
uh,
I think he did it to,
um,
to cro cop.
I've refereed him in Cro,
cop in Russia,
in Moscow.
And He,
uh,
he did on the cro cop.
Yeah.
That scarf all choke.
If you've got a real like you know,
like that guy,
like only nick does that kind of death grip.
Yeah.
Those guys,
which brings us to the last fight,
man,
that's a death grip that Ben asked her.
If I,
dude,
I watched that fight.
Uh,
I've watched that finished like 10 times trying to figure out what happened or
whether it was out or whether it wasn't out.
I was pretty convinced that at one point time he went out and then tomorrow
Uzman changed my mind.
Camaros [inaudible] showed the that we watched a video tape together.
He's like,
no,
he's giving a thumbs up.
And I'm like,
Shit.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'm still cause the angles I've seen haven't been the best.
I'm trying to see this thumbs up.
Was the thumb going up or was a thumb and a thumbs up position going this way?
Right.
Like on the,
as the arm drops was of the Times.
Okay.
So when I give somebody
a thumbs up,
like on a,
say somebody got a job.
Good job buddy.
Good job.
That's what,
that's what I want to do.
You know,
so I mean,
I don't know.
Like,
I mean I saw one of them's,
nobody's going to know whether he was conscious or unconscious.
What I saw,
I saw everything that would indicate I'm seeing that unconscious fighter.
I see an arm go limp for no reason whatsoever.
And um,
so that's what I'm,
that's what I'm have to work with because that's what,
you know,
we don't know what someone's feeling word I ever,
we just see if they're doing something,
it doesn't make sense and you see an arm go limp at that time,
you're going to assume that the person's unconscious.
We assumed it as the broadcast team.
They can hear you guys.
And,
and,
and that I'm supposed to do certain things and like,
so here's the thing with that choke,
when I'm refereeing fights,
you know,
there's sometimes where,
some positions or anxiety like,
uh,
you know,
you see two guys going after her leg locks,
you see a noodle mess of legs and you know,
you got to,
you're going to have to help one guy out and figuring out who's tapping and make
sure you're on the right arm.
When I see some chokes,
a rear naked choke,
especially the guy in the back face up,
I take a sigh of relief.
My job just got so much easier.
This guy,
you know,
it's not like he's going to go out and then a second take some extreme amount of
damage.
He may go out,
I'll have a second to make sure you're not even a second,
a half a breath to make sure he's okay and then let it go out.
And he's not going to take any other damage.
Bulldog choke.
We have anytime you have a choke where somebody where there's pressure on the
neck and there's been been in the c spine backwards like that,
that's a,
that's a rough situation for me.
So I see someone go limp and I know that on top of it,
they're no longer putting tension on their neck and their neck is just be in
bed.
I can't,
I,
you know,
I can't see that I should do something different than that because that's the,
um,
I,
I like to talk to people about this.
I'd like to talk to people.
I have opinions about fights,
especially people who are interested in who they know what they talking about.
Because if I always have a situation,
if I always have a mindset that I'm always doing the right thing,
I can't get better.
So I'm going to have to look at something and say,
was there a teachable moment there?
Is there a way I can learn from this?
And is there a way I could do something different?
And No,
I don't think.
I think with that same situation with the arm going limp with that type of a
choke on someone,
I don't know of a defense that requires the arm,
you know what I mean?
I would think to arm should be doing something else.
I at this time I don't,
um,
I don't see that I should do something different.
You know,
I'm always interested and always looking and always,
I love these types of conversations,
but right now I can't think of,
you know,
they sell you something.
It was an amazing fight.
It was.
Yeah,
it was.
It wasn't,
I mean,
first of all,
it was the first time I seen,
I refereed been asking,
I don't think I'd refereed him before.
And you know,
when you're in his PR,
his pressure is something special.
It's not the normal.
And,
uh,
the way Robbie dealt with it and Ravi hadn't been,
he hadn't been trouble.
You know,
I was so close to stopping that
fight when they're on the ground.
Yeah.
So many times.
With some bombs.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the amount of respect I have for those two athletes,
man.
It's like,
so that's,
so that's the thing is,
you know,
we never want to see anything that could make you have a feeling that it's
inconclusive,
but I can't think of what else I should have done.
But you know,
I mean especially for that,
that fight for those two guys,
you know,
you always want to,
yeah.
The people that have a feeling of conclusion there.
Well when we talked about on the phone when you brought up the,
the damage,
the possible damage,
that knack with the bulldog choked,
he might be cutting off nerves and you might be bending the spine in a kind of a
fucked up way.
I really hadn't considered that when,
not when I was thinking of the choke,
when he grabbed a hold of them.
I was just thinking it was a blood choke.
But you're right.
Like the way you lean in on a bulldog choke,
you lean back.
Yeah.
So a lot of pressure on the neck.
I've,
I've had,
uh,
some chokes where there,
I've,
I've refereed if I were a guy,
did one of these moves that you had to move for it?
A technique where he's been in the spine,
back twister.
It wasn't a twister.
Um,
the,
I think guys have a name for it.
You probably know the execution or is so that's what it was.
That's what it is.
Explaining to people.
The what that is is like if a guy is a okay turn not to cut you off.
Okay.
So for so long I've never really wanted to talk about it because people weren't
doing it.
This was years ago,
I saw it,
but now if there's a name for it,
I guess it's okay.
But you hadn't seen a lot of people doing it before,
right?
Well,
we uh,
we started doing it in 10th planet,
uh,
a few years back.
It's,
I think people have done it.
What it is basically folks,
it's like a guillotine from the back.
It's like taking a route you ever like rear naked choke cooks,
but instead of choking guides this way,
which is how you would do it,
which is a wrap your forum underneath his neck and wrap the other arm behind his
head.
Instead of doing that,
you wrap your arm all the way around the front like a guillotine hold,
but from the back and you have ungodly leverage.
Right.
It's ungodly.
How much pressure you can put on someone's neck.
And our friends,
Scott Epstein,
he uh,
he used quite a few times so we called it the executioner cause that it there,
oh actually I'm trying to find a picture of one.
I know this is,
this is the execution or choke.
This is a different choke out.
Uh,
he calls it the executioner.
I looked that up and nothing came up.
I,
okay.
I think I might have a,
have a have it here for you.
The something like this.
This is a little different.
This guy had arms in,
this is different,
but it's similar.
Yeah.
It's similar though.
That's similar.
Yeah.
You can have arms in,
yeah.
That's the same thing.
Yeah.
This is it.
That's 100% it.
So,
um,
I dunno what we're going to show people that either way it's a real bad place to
be in because this guy got it.
Yeah,
that's okay.
That's got Epstein,
that's still the north shore south choke.
But what he would do if he wanted to do an execution or is he would get his hips
underneath the guy and get 'em back position.
This is just a really good,
uh,
north south chose.
So yeah.
So what I saw was the guy who went north,
south and he,
ah,
this was years ago at a king of the cage and,
and way out in Wisconsin.
And he had a,
wow,
this is a long,
long time ago.
He had north south and he sat up once he,
he had the guy,
he sat up and pull it,
the guy's body up onto him and almost a sitting position and then put hooks.
And then I've done it before where you all rolled the guy to the side and I'm
going just to walk it through and figure out how it worked.
Um,
he put hooks and I was sitting,
I was like,
okay,
this isn't illegal.
If I stop this fight,
it's not,
you know,
or this is not an illegal move,
but I don't want to see how this plays out.
And the guy got one hook in and almost a second hook was about to go in.
The guy tapped and when I pulled him off,
the guy couldn't move.
His neck was fucked up.
Yeah.
He couldn't move.
Uh,
you know,
he got some sort of standard,
I don't know what's going.
And he was,
he was,
he couldn't move.
He was terrified.
I was terrified.
And,
uh,
then it kind of,
you know,
uh,
came back and came back and she says,
yeah,
I know of several guys that have gotten paralyzed because of a defense,
um,
from a guillotine or take your God now and when the tide,
yeah.
You know,
when someone gets you to your team.
Yeah,
I've heard of that.
Yeah.
So,
so that's why with some,
uh,
submissions,
you know,
especially some of the jokes,
it's like,
okay,
things are slowing down and okay,
things are going a little bit easier for me with that when things are not easy
at all.
That's not something that I wanna.
Um,
I want to play.
What I think if,
uh,
you know,
I've kind of disappointed with some,
some of people have a platform,
I don't want to mention any names,
but some people have a platform of kind of tossed it out.
It was something sensational and say,
Oh,
look at this as it wrong or right.
I think that's a little irresponsible when it's some,
uh,
dangerous techniques like that.
Well,
I think you really pointed that out about the neck and a very important word.
And I think that's something that people should really take into consideration.
When you see someone you've seen people,
uh,
have you ever refereed someone regard cotton?
A twister?
Yeah.
It's a horrible place to be.
It,
yeah.
Dot.
So it's a horrible place to be.
It's so your,
your neck is so fucked up and there's so much pressure and the fact that your,
that your left leg is isolated and your head's getting pulled through,
it feels like it's going to break it to fuck a place would be.
Even for the fact of the way it's set up,
because it's not like,
it's,
it's not like a fast thing that catches you off guard.
It's a long road to it.
So,
you know,
it's coming,
it's coming and you're like,
I'm doing this,
but I know how this is going to probably end.
And you're doing some little diff.
Yeah.
There's a chance.
I'm Joan Green Zombie.
I think he got the first ever one on Leonard Garcia.
I think that was the first day we'll get,
and that horrible dude that is so that it's so bad.
That feels so terrible.
Yeah.
And that,
that's uh,
he,
then there's def con four,
you take a rear naked choke grip from the twister position.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
That just,
you just rip and dude's heads cleaned off.
It's a horrible,
you know,
all those crazy like catch wrestling,
neck manipulation.
Right,
right,
right.
Those things to make my,
my neck hurt.
Just looking at them.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So anyway.
Yeah,
that's,
that's why I think,
you know,
you can't always say look at things as good or bad,
but you know,
some situations I've seen referees and in that one I think is a difficult
situation.
Not so I've seen other harder situations,
but you know what I mean?
Like it's an unusual one.
Yeah.
I mean,
we've seen quite a few bulldog chokes that puts someone unconscious.
Uh,
most recently,
uh,
Raquel Pennington against Ashley.
Evan Smith.
Crazy,
crazy fight for cal Pennington.
So fucking tough.
I mean,
that was just,
that was a crazy fight,
Matt.
It's just war and chaos.
And then with like one second to go,
she chokes her out and then lets her go and she's,
she's asleep from the bulldog choke and Ashley Evan Smith steps up covered in
blood.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
That was crazy.
But there's that one.
Um,
didn't Chris Lights out Lidell catch Tki in a bull dock choke?
I think he did a voice.
That's the title.
Yeah,
that's the,
yeah,
that one that looked really tight.
Yeah.
Go forget that Goto.
Yeah,
that's the one that Carlos Newton chokes out pat Miletich cause this was for the
title and he caught him in a bulldog choke and it's like,
that was what that was.
I don't think we,
we had a name for it.
I think we used to call it a school yard headlock,
but yeah.
Then somebody called it a bulldog choke at that time.
I remember people were calling it both.
Oh.
Like they are already had that and I don't know if it had there.
Maybe they gave it to,
but yeah,
it's a legit move.
Like it's a legit move.
Like if,
especially if you're a band asker type dude,
would that kind of grip someone's neck in that position?
Yeah.
It's horrible.
That was,
um,
that's why I say that referees have the hardest job because you're,
you're in that situation.
You do have to take those things into consideration.
What kind of damages is doing to this guy's neck?
Is he out?
His arm went limp.
Okay.
When do I stop?
I gotta get,
I gotta save him.
Like,
yeah,
know it that that is the tough part about it.
You know,
you were evaluating a situation is always there's different,
you know,
and you're evaluating a threat to the person you're evaluating.
If there's a threat coming you how much,
how well can they deal with it?
There's a lot of stuff on,
on there and you know,
we take it really serious.
I take it really serious.
It's a,
to me it's,
um,
it's a,
I feel that I have a sacred trust.
I feel that it's one of these positions that like,
um,
our athletes are not stupid people.
A lot of them could be doing a lot of things with their life and they've chosen
this path to a,
and they take time from their family,
they take time away from other careers where they could be progressing and all
to meet their dreams and hopes.
And I need to balance that with their safety.
So it's something I think about a lot,
you know what I mean?
I'm,
I'm a,
even in the way,
uh,
I talked to my friends,
you know what I mean?
To always,
uh,
you know,
I,
I'm always on,
I'm always working as a referee.
Anytime I'm out in the streets are with friends.
People are going to ask me,
what do I think about this fight or who do I think can be better and I,
because of this job you're doing,
you don't longer have the,
the luxury of having eat.
All of talking about mixed martial arts in the fun way about who's going to win
and how's this going to happen?
Because who knows?
I might referee the fight,
right?
And everyone's going to be on the Internet like hers referee in the fight and
we're having beers yesterday and guess what he told me.
Ah,
right,
right.
Yeah.
It's just,
you know,
so yeah,
I take it serious.
No,
you do it.
I'm glad you have that attitude.
What does this one right here?
Oh yeah,
this is awesome.
This is Carlos right here?
Yeah.
In the transition he grabs the neck and it's a crazy visual too because the
photograph,
the fruit to see the breaks right there,
right there,
I'm dies.
It's crazy.
Muscles and Carlos,
his arm and shoulder and neck.
Carlos Newton,
champion of the world
right there.
That moment and that crazy.
Carlos had some spectacular grappling real early on.
Man,
wild transition.
He was amazed.
Jitsu his,
uh,
his,
his explosiveness is agility.
I mean,
he was just,
he was so athletic.
He was doing stuff that no one else.
Yeah.
He also had a really high level,
a submission game early on.
Yeah.
We're like in 96,
97,
a lot of people didn't have that kind of a game.
And his,
his submission game was tight.
The Matt Hughes one was crazy.
Remember that?
Yeah.
That was crazy.
That a triangle choke where he had him up and he puts him to sleep.
And as they get up,
Matt Hughes,
like his,
you hear his car and are saying like,
stand up,
you won.
You won.
He's like,
what happened?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They'll double knockout.
Yeah.
I have that one.
I have one of the king of the cage,
a double knock out those right here.
This is,
look how God takes him strong.
He used was,
he was so fucking strong that if you build them up there,
okay.
And Carlos is trying to,
so he's,
he's,
he squeezes,
he squeezes.
So Matt goes unconscious,
he's out cold,
he doesn't know what's going on and no one knows what's going on and they get,
they,
so Carlos,
his head hit the ground when he went down like that and then knocked him out.
Right,
right,
right.
And then Matt woke up from the choke and then like you one go,
Huh,
look twice.
It's great.
That was a crazy scene that,
that scene was a tough one.
That was like,
what do you do there?
Yeah.
Well that was like the thing about this Robbie Lawler,
Penn Ashkan fight,
like,
Ooh,
mom was saying they got to run it back.
And I was like,
it wouldn't be a bad thing to run it back.
I mean,
well,
at the same time,
you know,
we got to be honest here,
like as far as running back.
Okay.
How many of the fights is that happened in the UFC?
Are there,
because it's exciting what people want to see.
Yeah,
most.
Right.
So Brock Lesnar DC is a perfect example,
right?
So that's exciting and people want to see it and some of the assignment been
generated by throwing
me under the bus but code give the people another time.
I'm,
I'm taking,
I got,
but yeah,
no.
So yeah,
I think um,
you know,
anytime that,
the athletes get to do what they do and people are going to watch it again and
people are going to be excited about it,
you know,
I don't know.
Well I don't think it's going to happen now.
At least not immediately cause a Mazda doll and Ben asked her and have a date
for July.
They're going to do that July show in Vegas.
That's a great fight.
I liked that fight a lot.
Right?
That,
that fights,
that's Mazda Dawson,
a new place,
man.
You could really tell he's something special right now.
Here's something really special.
When he knocked out till like that,
I was like,
whoa.
We knocked out cowboy.
It was like,
wow.
Yeah,
no muscle doesn't beast.
He's so good man.
And He seems like extra focused right now.
You know,
like,
I think he's probably like,
what is he 35 somewhere in that range.
How old is his heart or am I swear though,
he's either 34 35 he's coming on to having them on the podcast soon.
It's 35 and November.
Yeah.
So he's at that stage of his career,
um,
where you kind of like,
look man,
how much more time do you got?
Like realistically as a professional mixed martial arts fighter at 35 years of
age,
you know,
if you're Anderson Silvia,
you have like three more.
What do you have like three more years of his prime?
Two more years.
Something like that tend to be 38 39 like that's kind of it,
you know,
unless you're doing something,
unless you're doing something to spice up the pot.
All right.
You know,
like 40 41 42 man.
Tough.
Tough to compete.
Tough to come on the Nache.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a,
that's a whole nother TJ thing is a bummer.
That's a bummer.
If you don't know what we're talking about.
Tj Dillashaw tested positive for injectable EPO,
which is a serious performance enhancing substance.
And in some circumstances,
according to Jeff Novitsky,
it's given people strokes.
Um,
and I had heard this too,
that like young guys doing like Tour de France type shit would have strokes
because they were taking too much apo.
Cause you know,
like if you're supposed to take one,
take two,
fuck it
mentality,
this mentality's anybody who's going to do that,
you know,
I shit turns your,
your,
your blood to paint.
And I think that's what the,
I guess that's probably the discipline might have helped people were always
getting away with things beforehand,
right.
Is to try to,
uh,
maybe try to do it in a way where they,
won't get caught.
But I think that's like,
it will have this much is good then.
Yeah.
This is much more,
it's going to be better.
And,
yeah,
and we know guys who've done that with TRT.
You know,
there was a few TRT tests where they,
when TRT was legal,
testosterone replacement therapy,
um,
where you would hear about guys tested in like 14 hundreds,
14,
70,
like,
which is insane.
It's like superhuman.
No person's ever lived that as 1400,
uh,
like as a natural walking around testosterone level.
That's crazy.
Hyper human.
But they just get these benefits from that with some of these people though who
walk around naturally.
I wonder if they'd never been tested though.
That's true.
Some of these people I see walking around like genetic freaks.
They do.
Looks like he was born on Stuart's.
Yeah,
there are some freaks,
man.
There's some legit genetic freaks to deny.
That would be crazy.
There's some people that just like,
Yo all Ramiro,
what in the fuck?
It doesn't matter how many steroids you take.
It doesn't matter what you do like to do look like that.
You have to be a genetic freak and they're out there walking around.
It's not fair.
Well Yo,
I was talking about,
he was saying go to Cuba genes.
Go see the jeans.
Yeah.
Little Cuba look around.
What's his name?
Mom
fight or from France to heavyweight.
From France.
I mean he presents in Ghana for Francis.
And who wasn't a guy who used to be the one who had the,
the crazy fat would pat pat Barry.
Oh,
he checked Congo check Congo.
Adonis sculpted Greek statue.
He's just always imagine like I want to go to where he comes from.
Just take a look around.
Probably super athletes.
Probably a lot of eaters.
Um,
the TJ thing,
apparently they went and tested his old fight.
A piss with Cody too.
And that tested positive for EPO as well.
And then Cody start freaking out.
Yeah,
that's right.
What do you do if they,
if they go back,
like what if they decided to go back,
hey and say,
fuck it,
let's test all the fights and it finds out that he was doing it like five,
six,
seven fights.
What do you do?
Well,
yeah.
Then what do you do if you,
uh,
but then it's a whole nother can of worms too.
Because like all the fights and then what about all because right,
like when we get to test everybody chaplain's job and I were joking around last
night and I was like test them all and he's going,
no one task him all test everything.
Let's find out,
let's know what it was,
let's know what it was.
And he's like,
what if they had pissed samples from you know,
10 years ago,
15 years ago?
Like what if they could use Usada style testing today from the past.
I'm so glad that all these things are above my pay grade to deal with that.
Yeah.
I mean if I was the guys in the office right now,
the in charge of that program,
you have to really wonder where is the line.
You certainly want to test to guy for a fight that happened a week ago.
You certainly want to hold,
you know and check is if some new testing methods come out.
If there was a fight from a year ago,
you certainly would check that.
How many years back do you go though?
Yeah.
Especially if it's not expensive.
Like,
what if it's easy and cheap to do a test run 500 tests on the last 500
championship fights and then you have like 400 fights
that you now have to like change the result of
yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno either.
Last night I was joking,
I was saying test them all.
I was taking the,
the fun position test them all.
I don't know about,
I mean look,
we all know at one point in time performance enhancing drugs were a huge part of
mixed martial arts and that's why the UFC stepped up and decided to institute
this program.
It was a big part of it.
I think it's a big part of professional sports in general.
Sure.
100%.
Yeah.
And I think that,
um,
you know,
uh,
combat sports,
you know,
has a government oversight that other sports don't have.
So I think that were con we're going to be,
it's going to be coming up regardless anyway.
So I think maybe that's why the,
you know,
the UFC took a position,
right?
Because I think of the other sports.
I mean guys,
you get caught doing things,
but a lot of the other sports regulate themselves,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think the NFL regulates itself.
What did this Court House,
what are the sport,
has a government body like athletic commission saying,
Hey,
we're going to show up and do this or do that.
I don't know.
Like what do they do with baseball?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't know much about other sports,
but I didn't.
I remember,
I've never heard,
I've never heard of like a,
we all know about we,
you know that's something different.
Our support is that the government involved
commission would not,
not it,
not like he's seen a government commission,
but they just,
yeah,
take revenue themselves.
A NFL would have a vote.
They hand down a suspension.
They're not fair from this.
This guy suspension at that guy's suspension and baseball.
They have like a three strike rule,
like the first time it's like somewhere in the 10 to 25 game range and then the
second one is like half the season.
Third one,
you're out for a whole year and if you do it again,
your band.
Yeah,
but there's no outside Ghana shows up and decides to just at the baseball or NFL
and basketball on the side.
You have a big moneymaker in your sport and then somebody outside of your
company just comes along and says,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a government by,
they have the right to test this guy.
Yeah.
Like what happened with John Jones?
I mean that's,
that's a perfect example.
I mean the UFC did not want John Jones to test positive.
He is the biggest star right now other than Connor and Connor is not active and
Jon Jones is fighting all the time.
He wants to fight all the time that if the that's,
but that's the only way you ever find out what's really going on is you hire a
bunch of werewolves and they just let them loose.
Right.
Go check,
Piss,
go,
go out there,
check,
check everyone.
They checked the shit out of people.
I was looking at this list of people that Holly Holmes been tested more than
like I think,
I think Novitsky might've put it,
oh,
Steve Bay meo chick tweeted it because he'd been tested 38 times.
Really?
Yeah.
Some people,
it's like in the forties,
cris Cyborg got tested a lot.
Yeah.
And Holly Holm got tested a lot,
Huh?
Yeah.
Holly Holm got tested a lot.
A lot of people got tested.
Um,
it's
just a crazy numbers and a lot of them,
I guarantee they're waking them up.
Yeah.
Know,
get 'em up like six in the morning.
This what I've heard,
I mean,
I don't know what they go by.
I've heard conversations a little bit.
It doesn't seem like it's all,
they want to make sure you're there so that you get there really early in the
morning and fucked up.
You're supposed to tell him where you're supposed to,
where you're going to be at and think,
yeah.
Yeah.
The problem is if you're training hard,
that eight to 10 is so huge.
You might get hit with a punch if they wake you up after like six hours or five
hours.
It's possible that a punch might connect on you that wouldn't have connected.
If you've got eight that's not,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's real.
That's real.
Everybody knows how you feel good in the gym and everybody,
even if you just lift weights,
there's days you feel good.
There's days you feel like crap.
I made sure I showed up here.
Well rested.
You look well rested and I'm hydrated when we get back.
I did.
I did hydrate.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's just,
it's,
it's just not smart to stop athletes in the middle of their training camp at
wake him up.
Yeah.
I mean I get the testing but I feel like the testing so sophisticated,
you could get to them at noon.
Okay.
Just so you could get to them at noon.
You got good testing now just so we don't we,
I mean I don't know that.
I don't know that either.
I'm talking shit cause I think the best time,
the best time is that,
you know,
maybe at the earliest earlier the better.
Right?
Maybe I don't know the thing about this EPO apparently,
and this is what a Shahbaz telling me was that they didn't,
it didn't used to be a detectable,
uh,
the way it is now.
They've,
they've got these new methods of detection and a eps want to that apparently
from what I've read,
don't listen to me.
I'm not a doctor.
Um,
they can absolutely tell that you injected it.
It's uh,
it's injectable,
it comes in the injectable form.
That's what's in the body.
So it was no chance of a tainted steroid or tainted a supplement.
Right,
right.
It's definitely EPO.
So that's,
that's fucked up.
Cause apparently that stuff has a giant advantage.
Um,
it gives you an anabolic advantage.
It also gives you crazy recoup recuperative powers.
So like you could train really hard and then be ready to go the next day.
What do you think the answer is?
Because like for me,
like this is all stuff that like,
to be honest,
I don't really pay that much attention to it because I don't have,
I lost them.
It's out of my wheelhouse to deal with.
But also it's hard to have an answer.
Like you said,
it's like,
do we go back and keep testing them when these new things coming and says,
what do we do with the history tall?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's very interesting,
you know?
Yeah.
What do you do with the history books?
That's what you'd say.
Look at what point if,
if you have samples,
the date back 10 years to you do chest them all,
like what do you do?
I don't know.
I don't know how long they keep samples or how,
who has them or how they,
you know,
what's the chain of command?
Um,
I don't know man.
It's just,
but if you find out that TJ tested positive for the Cody fight to,
well,
Cody shirt has an argument there.
And what if it's the fight before that,
what have you,
there's a lot of that was,
a lot of people have arguments.
There's a lot of guys.
Yeah.
So it's,
yeah,
it's a tough,
to me it's a shame too because I'm a Tj fan and I think he's a phenomenal
fighter and,
uh,
I,
um,
I'm a big fan of watching him perform.
Um,
but just,
it taints his legacy.
It just does.
There's no way around it when,
when you get caught cheating,
which is this stuff is,
does no way.
It's not cheating.
I mean,
this is just cheating,
right?
I mean,
this isn't any accident.
It taints your legacy.
Right.
And the guy had an amazing legacy,
you know,
two times bantamweight champion,
one of the best pound for pound fighters,
the way he beat him and Barao I was like,
Holy Shit.
So he went out and fought Hanan Barao he was sparring with,
right?
Yeah.
His stuff to stuff.
Some of his fights were amazing.
He's amazing.
Again,
it doesn't take away from the fact that he's amazing.
Tj did an amazing fighter,
but fuck man,
that to test positive for EPO and Henry.
So Hutto foreigners is also crazy to watch the progression,
all the work he did and how much,
you know,
he was getting better every fight.
And so yeah,
but you've got to think like how much,
like if you're on EPO,
how much does that really allow you to train extra time?
How much does that allow you to recover?
What's the benefit?
Like what is the quantifiable benefit?
It must be pretty significant because there's a lot of,
you know,
the cyclists,
a lot of,
lot of heavy duty endurance athletes use it.
I almost want to try it,
you know,
they say that these executives are trying it.
They're doing EPO and entering into triathlons and shit like that.
For bragging rights.
Yeah,
just assholes.
Assholes with money or taking EPO.
Like really I was reading the thing about an epidemic of a really a boost to
that much like okay,
you're going to take it and you're going to notice that you're able to like,
like the other day you could barely finish a role,
a loop around the rose bowl at three mile loop and then you started taking it
and you're good.
Get what,
five,
six miles.
And I wonder,
I wonder,
I think what it does is it raises your threshold if you're already an elite
endurance athlete too.
I think for them that's what it is.
It's like they're already looking for that extra edge.
So they're already an elite endurance athletes are already in the Tour de France
and they take that APL and it's like,
well,
why just just Jackson mom.
They could just do more work.
They have more oxygen,
they don't run out of juice.
And for a guy like Tj,
his style,
so kinetic,
there's so much movement,
explosion,
swimsuits,
dances,
like he needs that juice.
It's not like a calm,
easy game where he's,
you know,
everything's fast,
fast,
fast.
It's crazy.
It's hard.
It's,
it's a hard one to swallow.
Yeah,
man.
So for me,
like I was like,
man,
I was going to come on Joe Rogan's show and let's see,
what was he?
Could he talk about to make me uncomfortable,
to talk about maybe some hearts stoppages,
man.
I either talk about some hearts,
but just
give me what's the worst,
well,
let me talk about what I made a mistake.
I don't want to talk about this
because I know I have no answer for it.
I don't understand that.
It's like,
oh,
I'd wanted,
like,
I just doesn't feel like a good conversation because all I could do is just,
it just get,
like you said,
it's just going to take away from what I've seen of Aza ends and the more I
imagine about it,
it's just going to be more takeaway and then anything I could say or think
about,
I can't think of anything that's solution
or our system.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't think anybody,
I think we're in this stage right now where they're probably looking at the data
going,
okay,
what does this signify and how many more people should we test?
You know,
once,
once they develop a new method of testing,
that's the whole reason why they want to keep the old samples anyway in case
new,
more sensitive methods of detect him.
Right.
Or invented
about this stuff.
Cause I know the true,
you're a science freak and you're a scientist.
Investi dark,
especially when it comes to,
uh,
anything that can enhance the,
this life that we have on this earth.
So yeah,
I'm
sure you know a lot about this stuff.
Well,
I've had a really amazing conversation with many people about it and uh,
David Sinclair was one of the more recent ones who did,
uh,
just discussion about life extension and different,
anti aging,
uh,
solutions and different things that they're coming up with.
But what I've come through with is at the end of the end is there are probably
hundreds of thousands of people that are involved in either legitimate
supplements or legitimate molecules or testing hormones on people or,
you know,
trying all these different things to try to figure out how to get the body to
perform better.
Some of them are legal and some of them are illegal and that's where it gets
strange.
She get like the guy like the ball co guy Vic to contact comes along.
It's like,
look,
I got,
why don't you just rub it on?
No one's going to know shit.
They don't know what this stuff is yet.
And for a while yet that worked.
And then,
but,
but wild worked.
Everybody's like,
why is Barry bonds getting so big?
You know,
people just started wrecking like,
come on man,
look at me.
Sammy Sosa looking at me in the eye.
What are you doing?
You know?
And they all,
they all like exhibited these obvious physiological changes were that you could
tell them whatever they were doing was really effective stuff.
There's hundreds of thousands of people working on that right now.
All the time on all the time trying to get it better.
There's probably thousands of people that are trying to come up with stuff that
sneaks past this testing,
you know?
Did you ever see,
I'm so,
I just stick to Bikram Yoga,
man.
It's a good move.
Did you ever see that ICARUS documentary?
I think I did.
It was about who?
It was a,
the Russian.
A doe anti dog.
Did you see that one?
I didn't see that.
It's amazing.
The guy who made the documentary,
the whole thing sort of happened by accident.
So a guy named Bryan Fogel and his um,
his documentary was on,
he was going to do a bike race and then he was going to come back the next year
and do the bike race on steroids and see what the difference was.
And so he was going to document it all and he was going to have this Russian
anti-doping guy.
Um,
this guy was going to oversee his program,
tell them what to take and how much to take and when to take,
make sure he doesn't get cut.
It was no,
yeah,
make sure he didn't get caught.
That was one of them I think.
I don't think they drug tested most of the things that he was interested in
doing.
I think the thing he was doing,
he just wanted to see how good he could get.
Okay.
Cause you said antivirus and anti doping gun.
This is,
this is why,
this is where it gets too.
In the middle of him doing this,
this Russian anti-doping guy,
it comes out that the Russians cheated at the Sochi Olympics and this Russian
anti-doping guy spills the beans to this guy and explains the Russian state
sponsored doping program that they state sponsored and doped all their athletes
that everyone was on steroids and that they hid the urine.
They had two separate legal like you let a Sebring secrets separate room where
they transferred the dirty urine through a hole in the wall and slipped out the
good urine.
They put it back in place so they,
they substituted clean urine for the year and that was collected.
They opened up the bottles.
They found these microscopic scratches on the supposedly on OpenTable cap these
bottles,
but they ran them under microscopes.
They like look,
they were scratched.
These,
these things had been open.
The Russians had figured out a way to open the bottle without cracking the seal.
Did they?
They swapped piss.
I mean,
it was like super sophisticated stuff and this guy details all of it by accident
just because he had hired this guy to give him drugs so he could,
he was just trying to run a document.
It,
let's see how much better steroids make me at riding the bike.
And when all this stuff broke,
he just came in at the right place at the right time.
And it's amazing.
It's amazing.
That's why Russia one,
like all these gold medals in the Sochi Olympics,
there were all Jews to the tits.
And you're saying all of them,
Huh?
Yes.
It's just for me,
like it's,
it's just,
it's one of those things like I just don't have no help and answer to it.
I know there's always going to be people who are going to look for an advantage
and I think as long as some,
but there's one person looking for an advantage,
then,
uh,
I think there's some people are going to have the attitude that if there's an
advantage out there,
I'm a fool for not taking it.
Uh,
the people who don't take it or people who are,
are gifted in some way or have just had a work ethic that goes beyond and it's a
matter of pride that they don't do it.
You know what I mean?
Like when you're a sharp kid,
you don't,
it's like a matter of pride to never cheat on a test.
Whereas some people that's their go to,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting.
It's like what is,
what's legal and what's not legal?
Like what should you be allowed to do?
You should you be allowed to use cryotherapy.
What if it turns out the crowd ramps up
your hormones would,
if it turns out the cryotherapy speeds up your recovery that's commensurate with
a steroid.
But why shouldn't you be able to use it?
You should be able to,
but I'm just,
I'm just saying cause I think the basis of the is that some of these other
things are supposed to be maybe dangerous for you.
EPSS sure.
That that's the reason that's the base that I don't know if that,
but I think that's our base reasoning.
Right.
I think the base reasoning is cheating.
Well,
no,
not just cheating because it's not cheating if everyone's doing it well for
sure.
I mean,
so they're supposed to be dangerous stuff,
so like you don't even know.
But I'm talking about hormone.
Like you can use vitamins or anything or you can have good nutrition.
It's that makes anti anything that's gonna make you better at what you're doing.
But there's ones that we don't want people to use because they're dangerous to
use for those reasons is the,
I think that's supposed to be the reason,
right?
I do not know if that reason makes sense.
I know not saying whether it makes sense or not,
but I think that's supposed to be the cause we were,
where are they going to come?
When does it come down and say,
well,
we don't want you using any artificial supplements,
vitamins.
We want you to get all your vitamins from your food.
What you're doing is you're getting some of your vitamins artificially and it's
not the way human being gets it.
So like there's a line that's being drawn somewhere and I'm saying the line is
being drawn at what is supposed to be saved.
One at one point it got drawn at that and then became something else.
Maybe.
I don't know if they were really concerned with safety,
they wouldn't let them fight or we're not talking about Tom about all sports.
I know,
but I mean,
especially like with fighting,
if you're really concerned with safety,
let's just cancel the whole event.
Like someone's gonna get hurt.
Well,
there's a lot of things I said,
you know that we don't like to fighters to jump on the top of the cage who,
because
they were just kicking each other,
kicking each other in the face.
But yeah,
yeah,
no,
get off.
Get down off of that.
Kay,
are you doing up there celebrating a bad day?
Yeah,
the celebrating thing is funny man.
Let them celebrate and they don't like him to do a flip.
Well,
one guy,
he did a flip and landed on one guy did a flip and landed on someone.
So I get that.
But it's like,
man,
I trust the guy to get kicked in the neck,
but I'm not going to trust him to do a flip.
He's probably done a flip before.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Either Gates.
He almost landed on a guy his last fight.
Yeah,
and that's what that somebody else gets hurt now.
Now I get that.
What if he killed a doctor?
Who knows how long?
How much of a suspension do you get if you kill a doctor with a backflip?
Like for real,
I imagine the doctors running in and just going there to help.
Dang.
It would be the ultimate worldstar video de de Beast would,
would uh,
Derek Lewis,
would he have that on his Instagram?
What do you keep them as Instagram?
If someone died,
it was a UFC,
he might,
he's so savage.
His Instagram is pretty funny in the game.
If you want to see,
I saw one the other day of a guy on a motorcycle on his Instagram,
drove right into a fucking telephone.
Paul Guy wasn't paying attention or something.
He went off the side of the road and a fucking telephone pole full on.
Oh.
Just slammed into this poll like,
fuck man,
I got to stay off.
Derrick's good.
No,
I don't like to watch that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
like that guy's never going to be the same.
He's either dead or he's never going to be the same.
Yeah.
That's the one I saw was that one where saw that guy was going to do a jump off
a house and two of Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you don't know what happened,
man.
That guy's got to be dead.
A lot of them are dead.
I'm mad,
man.
I just got something on my Instagram about the guy who got hit by a dolphin.
I just put that up there the day I saw somebody put it up.
Can I get hit by a dolphin?
Yeah.
He was doing some paddle boarding as a dolphin was living life a little bit.
Dolphin was doing,
the sticks are there.
You know how the paddle board down,
there's a wave coming and then you can see the dolphins.
You know they like to surf,
so they get in the wave,
they're doing their thing and I think the dolphin sees him.
He's the only one who decides to come out of the water and get a little air.
He's like,
oh,
it was a paddle boarder.
Get a little air bow and he fucks him up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Here we go.
Whoa,
let me this backer.
Oh,
that's 100% on purpose.
Like it makes you wonder about dolphins like a dog.
I was like,
oh,
what an opportunity.
It is.
100% on purpose.
Yeah.
I had to,
I had to put that.
I had to post that on Instagram.
That guy's all right.
He's already dead.
He fell in the water.
But a dolphin's heavy.
Yeah,
I checked.
She's got a little side chat.
What do you do in that moment?
Do you hit him?
Do you hit the Dolphin?
Do you punch it?
You know,
I have respect.
I know.
No been trying to fuck you.
I'm like,
the Dolphin got the air.
Hey,
you're having a little fun.
Yeah.
Cause how much did the dolphin way and it's his element.
It's a big animal.
Yeah.
You've got to get back to the shore.
That is pretty funny though.
Yeah.
Walked out one off,
walked that when
you know,
elbow it as it's coming and you don't want to piss him off.
You're in their neighborhood
and this is,
that's clearly on purpose.
Yeah.
Let's clear that.
It was like,
you fucking dumb.
He's get out of the way,
bitch.
What are you doing?
You're not even surfing paddle boarding panelists.
Surprising you hard.
I wonder if his friends laughed the other dolphins.
Yeah,
he's talking to us.
They probably thought it was awesome.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I went paddle boarding.
It's not easy.
I didn't think it was hard.
Did you stand?
He was standing straight like this.
You don't have to go.
That was hard.
There was a lot of waves.
It was a,
it was a little,
was a little walkway,
but I was like,
I thought this would be way easier.
I fell twice.
She was making fun of me.
Stop it,
Bro.
Yeah.
I'm paddleboarding.
Um,
is one of those things where it's like,
Eh,
it's just used mostly easier core,
right.
You're bouncing it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm not an expert at it.
I did it once or twice when I was in Hawaii,
you know,
hanging out with the fam.
I'm stuck.
If you got like placid water,
it actually calming Paddle Board.
You ever surf?
I've trying.
I'm going to be sad.
I'm going to do it this year.
This is to get
some lessons,
taking some lessons and did a little bit.
I have,
I've,
I've been,
uh,
up on some way of the water was pushing me,
but I can't,
I'm under,
can't call it surfing what I was doing,
but I was in the water.
I was having fun.
That's a respectable thing to know how to do.
Right.
When you hear someone can serve like,
ah,
well,
no,
I've decided that I have to do it.
I've been living in California all my life.
I'm paying to be a surfer.
I live here.
I pay the,
the,
the surfing.
Gwinnett tech.
Yeah,
the surfing tax.
But I'm not going to the beach and getting my money's worth.
I got to go and get it.
Yeah.
When we think about how many people live in La,
how few actually
beach
beach is not that crowded.
No comparison.
How many fucking people live here?
It's one of those things where people just take it for granted.
Yeah,
so who do you serve?
No,
you know what?
I'm scared of sharks.
Yeah,
so I started the quest last year,
so last year I took a couple of lessons,
so this gets a little warmer.
I'm going to do it again.
We were thinking about doing a surfing challenge for sober October.
It was going to be like time spent up on a board for the entire month long camp
or contest.
Are you going to be doing it?
We haven't decided and I think the guys are,
they don't want to do the surfing thing.
If you do it,
let me know.
I'm want to do it with you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
cold in October,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
That's the idea.
Pussy come on.
Fear held in October,
barely.
It's like acs September.
With this,
it happens very fast.
The way I thought this is a navy or a French navy men jumped off about to
celebrate and as he was in the water here,
a shark comes after him.
Yeah.
It just comes out of nowhere.
They can't,
no one can really see it.
Then all of a sudden right at the last second this,
they spot it and they're like,
oh shit,
get the fuck out of the way.
It just nibbles.
I got of split a little,
it almost looks fake,
but the way he reacts,
it's not like,
I don't think that shit's fake at all.
It just happened.
All of a sudden he's just in the wire.
They didn't.
Yeah man.
That's how it goes.
That's their world.
Look at.
You can't even see anything in there.
That's the thing that freaks you out the most about the ocean is the
possibility.
It's like you're just looking down.
You don't see a god damn thing and also the meg done.
I liked that Australian guy remember that Australian share for and the shark was
coming after him and he was just pushing him away.
He was in there when he talked about,
he said,
well,
he was looking like he wanted to bite me.
I decided I didn't want him to,
so I just push him away a little bit.
Yeah,
you just fought off a shark.
He's like,
yeah,
I didn't want to be bitten,
so that's a good attitude.
Occasion.
Yes.
I'm not interested in this.
I'm not freaking out,
but I still want to be bit,
yeah,
you don't want to freak out.
Right.
If you freak out that,
they probably can sense it.
If she really spazz out in the water,
they probably know all this kind of scared as fuck.
I time to east guy smells like food.
They apparently don't like to eat us
right here.
8 million views.
Great White Shark surprises.
Solitary surfer.
I haven't seen this one.
This is not the one I'm talking about
swimming,
right?
Oh,
it's going to be seminar.
I don't look right behind him.
Oh Jeez.
Louise's
surf.
I caught it there.
No,
I think he saw it and he's like,
oh man.
But he's paddling his arm with every time he paddles,
the arm could disappear on him.
She's going to surf.
Yeah,
five,
five but you are so helpless in their world.
It's like you ever see what happens when a shark,
it's beached.
I was looking for this video that a day we found that one where you were like
white.
Just pick it up and throw it out.
I get in the water.
There's a video.
I saw a girl literally doing that just like a chick in a bikini.
There's,
this is a smaller shark,
but she just grabbed him by the tail yanks it good for her,
does it out,
but the problem was with the one you can't see sharks don't just start swimming
when they would get put in the water that they need to be.
It's like they can't stop moving really,
so they got to have a little shove the,
it's hard to do too.
They had to drag that shark out by a boat to sort of get it going to get water
and its gills so it can breathe.
Oh,
okay.
That makes sense.
It's got to be going to,
the water's got to come this way because sharks are super weird in terms of
their physiology.
Like if they go upside down and go to sleep.
All right,
Jason Sharks and just fucking strange and they have to keep moving.
I don't think they,
they can't breathe if they sit still,
unless they find a spot where there's a nice little draft.
Oh,
right,
right.
Did he also happened to you?
I can't share this one either cause this is gonna get taken down,
but it's a girl getting pulled into the water.
She's trying to feed a shark off of a boat and it grabs her by the finger and
just yanks her and,
oh gee.
And everybody freaks out.
Also.
It's quick,
fast.
What kind of shark is it doesn't say,
but also that's in Australia.
So it might be,
yeah.
Fuck that.
I understand.
Why does she think she could feed a shark with her fingers?
I told her she could and that was a bad idea.
The worst thing,
you know,
you're probably right cause you know,
like when you're,
when you haven't done it before,
you're going to make,
you're going to ask a reasonable question.
Can the shark bite me and pull me in and there's going to tell you something and
the expert voice like,
no,
he's not interested in you.
You don't look like a seal.
He's not going to try to bite you.
Plus she's probably hanging out with like three or four dudes that want to fuck
her and they're all drunk.
Yup.
They want to show her a good experience.
So I was giving her bad advice.
She gets half of her finger removed.
Fuck then nobody's happy.
Yeah.
You,
what do you like going to Russia so much?
I do.
Dean join up there.
Yeah,
I do.
That's a lot of time.
Let me say.
Um,
well I like 'em,
I like traveling so this is a cool thing.
I've got to travel so much.
I haven't got to see a lot of really cool places and uh,
uh,
Russia is one of them.
I like all the different places I've been there.
Saint Peter's cool cause Russian,
one thing is it's like America,
lots of different places,
wherever you are.
Like,
you know,
this America to some people could seem like a different country,
different states that summer.
Yeah.
So it's like that.
So,
um,
I got to,
uh,
I go to Moscow Moscow's one thing,
you know,
you get to,
there's a lot of history,
a lot of Nice things to see.
Saint Petersburg,
same thing.
Um,
do you feel safe when you're over there?
Well,
I take everything at face value.
So as I,
that's the way I go through life because if I was to try to always read some
undercurrents or read what people tell me I'm supposed to experience,
I am,
I'm not,
I'm never going to do anything.
Like I'm a long time ago,
my travels,
my,
um,
I was going to go do one a buttered being show down in Alabama and my parents
were like,
man,
you're going to Alabama,
be safe down there.
Don't be doing all that stuff.
He'd do,
you know,
it's going to be different because of,
American,
our history with racism.
And,
uh,
I went down there and I was,
you know,
this is what the experience,
uh,
you might even tell the story because this is a story.
So I went down there,
I was,
I was at the show and,
and there's some cops come up and they look like the cops from,
you know,
in the movies from the south that you're supposed to scare you.
And I took a picture with them and they're like,
and somebody else came to take a picture and you're like,
well,
look,
when we started going,
Oh man,
I'm gonna do this song.
This is what I'm here to do.
I mean,
he hang out with people and I'm a referee fights and,
you know,
talk to people they want to talk.
So I took a lot of pictures.
They were impressed.
They were saying that,
you know,
they've seen other people,
tell people know about pictures and the guy all side,
they're like,
hey,
um,
we want you to come out and pull people over with us.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do,
I have no interest in doing that.
You know,
I grew up in La,
you know what I mean?
Like they're like,
and they're getting pumped it like imagine like you're getting pulled over by
herb dean pitch.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
no,
I don't want to do it.
And uh,
then one goes on,
he goes,
well,
we'll some do some,
I've been wanting to make us do some tase me or something hurt.
And so like he grabs this,
his taser gun and sticks to Taser in my hand.
She's,
and I'm sitting there and I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I started tasing him,
right.
He's in this guy and he's like,
I'm like a,
um,
have.
So then,
um,
I,
after the tasing,
uh,
his buddy,
one of the,
um,
agents and one of the guys was working with me,
comes up and tells him that he has some business to talk about with me.
I go,
Hey,
what'd you want to talk about?
It goes,
man,
I could see you so uncomfortable with what was going on that I just wanted to
get.
I was like,
thanks.
So I get back to him.
I give back to my hotel room and I,
I was thinking,
I was like,
man,
you know,
I'm worried about people prejudging and being intolerant.
I'm prejudging of these guys because of uh,
some history and these guys are really cool.
If I ever get the opportunity seize guys,
I'm going to be,
you know,
man and I,
and I did,
they came like right then the phone rings,
I swear.
And they took me to an after party and really like yeah,
they took it like,
and it was like the place looks like roadhouse and you know what I mean?
Like the hell,
everything you see like in a movie,
like,
like you know some,
you know,
hey,
your wife's not going to be happy about that and,
and I'm going to catch you next week.
One of types of things,
right?
Yeah.
Drove me to the airport with the lights on.
It's good,
I think.
I think I still have the picture of me tasing him.
I could show it to you.
It was,
it was like,
it was a pretty cool experience.
So after that I was like,
man,
whatever.
I think I know about things.
I really don't.
And so,
uh,
so I take things at face value.
Yeah.
I've had good times in Alabama.
I've had good times in the south.
I think the world's changing too.
I really do.
I think there's parts of,
especially this country,
we almost everywhere you can find cool piece.
So,
so,
yeah.
So I mean if,
uh,
you know,
oh my God,
that is hilarious.
So,
so that should put this on your Instagram.
Can you?
Yeah.
Can that they wouldn't mind.
I've talked to those guys about it.
Don't you think he's going to get in trouble though?
No,
he's not going to said he's fine.
He said it'd be all right.
I thought he would get in trouble,
so I didn't want to know.
Yeah.
That's why I haven't put it on.
No,
that's why I never did that.
But I've actually talked to him.
So anyway,
this,
um,
that,
yeah,
that's a big lesson to me.
Like,
Hey,
don't,
don't think you know what's going on.
You know,
take things at face value.
Try to beat,
you know,
when you've go to Russia,
you take that attitude like let's just see what the experience or you have your
own experience,
what Russians and I'm going to have my own experience and not let it be what
anyone else's.
And also,
I had been the Russia before I went in [inaudible] 95 I used to work for a
company that made documentaries,
these guys.
And I ended up going along to help him out with,
it was the first time I'd ever left.
The U S is a big,
had a big effect on me.
So I,
um,
do you know how to speak it?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I can,
I can do my,
I can do my instructions at and I know some words.
I mean,
I took some time to learn how to use the alphabet so I can get around and help
me.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
like Celtic ancient,
so really care what it's called.
Is that what it is?
It's a guy named surreal.
So I thought what houses cyrillic here,
but it's actually named after a guy who made it.
That's the,
the Russian stuff.
What does that Celtic stuff that you know the,
you know the Oh yeah,
those,
those rooms.
The little rooms or something?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The letters in Russia.
Like why is it that,
why would they do it backwards?
Like it's the same letter that we have,
but it's backwards.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
That's a,
yeah,
you're talking about,
is that what it is?
He has the one that looks like a backwards are.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
that's what they,
that's the yacht.
What does that stand for over there?
Just means Yah.
Yah.
And it's,
we use it,
like I told you that we have that chaos.
So that's how you say hi.
You say look at their fucking language and what's up with that age?
What's up with that?
Ups.
H's.
H H is the end.
That's how you use it in.
Oh my God.
So like when you,
so once you get used to read to you,
you always see pectal pile everywhere you go.
Right?
What's that?
Lemons restaurant.
What's the upside down little age.
So it looks like a candle holder.
Yeah,
right there.
What's that?
Yeah,
that's an upside down h what happened there?
So we took that ancient dumped it on its head,
but it looks like h and it doesn't it if you flipped it upside down,
it's a quick look at the e below that.
Like what the fuck is that thing?
And so that's a yacht that backwards are.
Yeah.
So you would say you would use it like Ja and say that word when you use it like
a hey,
like just how we use hi.
Oh,
hi.
And we usually like I,
and then we might use it in another reason too.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I mean it is kind of amazing how different the way we write is to the way
Asian folks to real freak out.
That's,
and I,
I think you just have to learn it,
right?
Each one of them.
When you have to learn each and every one of those there demean.
It seems,
it looks like it's pretty hard to learn.
Well,
it looks,
especially if it's not completely ingrained in your memory as a child,
because I ended up late in life.
I know there's some people who speak mandarin,
but they can't write it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck man.
It's alien.
Looks Alien mean that the fact that a whole different side of the world writes
that way and these little characters.
So I do have some help when I go over there.
I'm going to tell you some,
I got married a few years ago.
My wife is Russian.
Ah,
there you go.
Yeah,
and she speaks Chinese.
So when I go to China region,
right.
It's tiny.
So when we go to these countries and writes,
she,
it's easier.
They're like,
wow.
And English or no.
Anyway,
so we get along because some people are good with languages.
Man That's incorrect.
Or Spanish is better than mine.
I already just got here to have Russian,
which has its own use of the alphabet and then Chinese,
which is another whole deal.
And English just,
does she have room in our head for anything else?
I know a hard drive would be full.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's just as those three languages,
like fuck three hard languages.
Right.
Probably the hardest.
I heard the rush as hard and and English.
Well I'm not going to say heard,
I tried to trying to learn it.
It's hard.
There's so many ways to say something cause they conjugate a lot.
I think they a lot more than Spanish.
And that's what I have problems with.
You know,
we all get Spanish words,
we live in La but conjugating verbs that you know,
she can do it easy cause she's like,
oh cause they conjugate so much more.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's,
that's might be the three hardest language to learn outside of.
Maybe the other one other Asian languages like Japanese is probably pretty
difficult too.
When I heard the Vietnamese,
it's tough.
Yeah.
And then you know,
you got those languages that you look at,
you know.
Wow,
that's great.
And then you see like ancient Hebrew look at Hebrew language,
like the way they write.
Like what the fuck?
I don't know.
I bet Arabic stuff Arabics it's gotta be tough.
I mean how many languages are there?
If you had to guess?
Yeah.
A hundred,
a hundred days,
doesn't dialects and depending on like where you are,
even in Mexico there's different,
right?
Yeah.
Speak the same Spanish down there.
Even in Spanish he had like you can under like,
cause you know,
I took a couple of Spanish classes.
Right.
But I can understand people from,
from,
you know,
uh,
Spain easier for some reason I grew up right here.
It's harder for me to understand the way they speak Spanish.
My friend lives in,
um,
my friend Adam Green tree,
he lives in Australia and uh,
he has a lot of experience with like the indigenous people that live there
because he works in a mining company and they deal with a lot of the aborigines.
And um,
they have uh,
the,
the groups of people they call the mobs.
That's what they call themselves instead of like a village or clan or the calls
off a mob.
That's what,
that's what aboriginal issues and they have different languages for different
moms.
So like there might be hundreds of mobs and this area and they all have
different languages.
So you drive.
I go how close?
He was like a few miles.
I go a few miles,
you know he would say kilometers wide.
It might be 2,800 kilometers like so you got a hundred kilometers and you've got
a totally different language.
That's all the different languages is a map of all the,
maybe they're similar,
right?
Areas of the mops?
I don't believe so.
I think they don't know what the fuck each other are saying.
Right,
right.
That's why we can't understand Australians.
Right.
If you look at that,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Like I don't know who's documenting all this stuff and what whether or not
they've saved these languages and they,
they have in it.
Cause it's very likely that like little ones of them will just go,
you know,
if these people assimilate the other populations or move out,
like you might lose these languages.
Yeah.
Here's what I like about going to Russia to,
cause there's so many different cultures and so many people and I liked it.
I like people like I get to,
I got to like a,
I get to go to Graziani,
haven't been got to,
I've been to Dagestan to grass.
Knee is in Chechnya.
Yeah.
It's really,
it was a really cool place.
I went to a show you some pictures,
went to uh,
uh,
went and looked him my well because it's,
for me what's really cool about it is the energy that people have about
developing over there right now.
Because the place,
there was a war there,
you know about that,
right?
Yeah.
There was a war and a right now and they're really building up and they're
really excited about it.
So I think it's just,
uh,
it's cool to go and see people who are really,
a cui kind of a group mentality about moving forward,
you know?
So what,
where exactly is this and what was their war?
You're to Chechnya.
Yeah.
So they had a war with Russia,
right?
Oh,
civil war.
So see that's what it used to look like.
Yeah.
Now you've got a picture of it now,
right?
Yeah.
So it's the,
ah,
there it is now rebuilding.
Yeah.
And there's that rebuilt their,
their energetic about it,
and there's pride of then it's,
and it's cool is a cool to be able to go there and get to see it.
That is cool to see something in the middle of a rebirth like that.
Right?
Yeah.
It's beautiful.
And in that area,
a lot of the places,
yeah,
there's a lot of rebirth energy going on.
Oh Wow.
So that's what it looked like right after the war.
God Damn.
Wow.
That's a crazy image.
So you've been this now,
uh,
traveling around the world like this for how many years?
For a long time.
I think.
Um,
let me think.
I mean,
I see,
I probably would,
we're doing stuff with MMA a and traveling for the sport I've got,
I started probably traveling around to travel around internationally,
around 2003 or four.
Wow.
And then,
um,
but I got to travel around the US a lot before that,
so that was really cool.
Got to go to places like,
you know,
uh,
that I would never go to a Indiana someplace in Indiana.
I'd never go or you know,
and,
and some of these,
um,
I've got to go all through the,
throughout most of the states in the u s uh,
because even before I was doing a lot of the UFC,
I refereed for king of the cage.
So by the time I got to the UFC,
I got to referee more fights than anyone I knew.
I think I met you at a king cake.
Yeah.
Way Back in the day.
Communicate.
We met there.
Yeah.
That was like 2000 what?
I was probably 2001 or 2000.
That was when they were an Indian reservation.
It's probably 2000 cause they started there in 2000 and you're there at the
early ones,
right?
Yeah.
When they first started,
Eddie was,
Eddie was a working for them.
Yeah.
And my friend Bud Brotzmann was,
yeah,
yeah.
Bud Men.
But didn't like Terry decided to let me referee bud,
but her was hard on me at first.
Really?
Well,
yeah.
Bob was roughing,
but now,
but then he started to like me,
but it was rough on me.
You didn't want you to referee it first with they,
Larry was about it.
That's how I started refereeing.
Larry was very,
was a referee and I trained with Larry and uh,
everybody liked Rarey.
Larry as a referees are really,
you know,
there is a really good guy and he did a lot to um,
uh,
he went and when he started doing it,
he went and did a little research and,
and uh,
you know,
talk to people from the commission from doing boxing and kickboxing and you
know,
so he put inspectors in place and things like that.
And that was my job at first.
I will go out there and we'd bring all our guys out and I would like kind of
manage the inspecting team and um,
uh,
then,
I think they ended up working me too hard one show.
And I was like,
man,
I came in,
volunteer my time,
I want to be able to see at least a fight or two.
And I had just come to work for you.
And,
uh,
Terry,
it was like,
oh,
I'll make it up to you and I want to try reference.
I was like,
let me,
I'll try referee if I goes okay,
do that.
And then I remember the first time it was like,
man,
I think when I was like,
wow,
I really signed up for something here.
You know what I mean?
So yeah,
it was,
but yeah.
That's Kinda how that happened.
When did you,
you,
you've had,
how many fights did you have?
Oh,
I've had,
I think a five.
And when did you decide did the,
was it because of refereeing that they decided that it wasn't,
it was a conflict of interest for you to continue your career?
Well,
see,
I was never like a real serious competitor as like,
I like to train,
I like to do that.
And then every now and then,
ah,
I'm wanting something to train for,
you know what I mean?
And so give me something to motivate me or I'd be fun to do it,
you know?
Um,
and what happened is someone told me that it was a conflict of interest and
that,
uh,
I needed to pick one or the other and a,
and no one's gonna miss me as a fighter.
So,
so,
you know,
that's,
that's kind of how that worked out.
Well,
you're
definitely one of the best in the world,
man.
I get happy when your referee in a fight because I know that it's going to be
handled the row,
I mean I agree with you on virtually every single time you and I've had a
discussion about what should or shouldn't be done.
Um,
the one thing that drives me crazy about referees and not you,
but some referees is breaks and stand ups that don't necessarily need to happen.
When guys are working towards something and you can see there's like a battle,
the guy trying to defend guys trying to get out of half guard to get an amount
and then you'll see a referee come over and just separate it because they're the
crowd's booing or because they don't understand what's happening.
How much of a struggle it is.
Right.
Especially clinch work.
Exactly.
The guys get a guy up against the cage,
there's,
they're working for something.
They might stall each other out,
but eventually someone might break down.
Right.
I mean,
and this is how a guy looked,
Norma Madoff wins,
fights against elite guys.
This is how Randy coture one,
a lot of fights.
It's a legitimate tactic.
Yeah.
Cause it doesn't look fun for you.
You know,
like a guy beating a guy up against the cage,
just short elbows,
knees,
the thighs.
You might think that that's not enough.
But that's,
that's uh,
that's a good way to where a dude out and you keep doing that until eventually
you break them.
And especially when you're someone like Steve Bay or,
yeah,
I think,
I think for me it's helpful as I do my pre-fight instructions,
you know,
so I tell the fighters what I expect and what to expect from me,
you know what I mean?
So I don't want to,
I want to interfere as little as possible.
Yeah.
I know you do.
And so that's,
that's my goal.
And so I,
you know,
I give him instruction.
If I tell him,
you know,
hey,
work,
work what I expect and you know,
I expect you to do something too.
I'm,
well,
I'm looking for big shots or advance your position.
And then they'll ask me like,
well how much,
how long will you leave something stale?
I go,
well,
what is still,
if they're both guys were relaxed that still,
but like you're talking about even up against the fence and a clinch,
especially that's where a lot of things are really getting decided.
And so we have to really see that play out.
You know,
especially a lot of the guys are,
you know,
if they're,
they're striking it each other,
maybe in some of the other weight classes,
you know,
uh,
then they don't have that one punch all ways.
Uh,
some of the guys do,
but not everyone does.
And that's where things are going to get cited in that clinch.
And if there's a tension,
if there's a tension there,
we need to see where that's going to go and let it work itself out.
I'm so glad you said that.
That's a perfect way to say it.
And the,
that's absolutely a hundred percent agree.
And there's,
there's moments where it changes the course of the fight where it's really
unfortunate.
Um,
you didn't referee Camaros and Damien Maia did do and I don't think so.
Whoever did that one,
we don't even have to pull it up,
but there was a moment in the first round when Damien Maia got ahold of tomorrow
and was trying to take his back standing and he had like one hook in and a
clinch and he was hanging onto him and the referee decided not enough was taking
place.
They separated them.
I'm like,
Oh,
you can't do that.
So hard to get ahold of [inaudible] wasn't me.
Who did that Guy Damien Maia about to get you back?
Whoa.
I said,
no,
that's not going anywhere.
And that Sarah went crazy.
You know,
he has that,
um,
that podcast.
He does what?
Jim Norton and he's like,
you just don't do that until the guy like,
he's,
he's got ahold of him.
Like he,
he might take his back here like,
yeah,
like in,
you know,
you saw what he did with Lyman good when he takes your back in Lima goods
appeased.
But when Damien Maia gets a hold,
especially early in the round,
it's fresh and he's got his back already and then he has a lot of interesting
take down from there too.
While he's like,
he goes,
goes back and forth with Taf way taking your back and then one year definitive
take down,
he starts taking your back and then when you go back then he's back working on
yet.
So no,
he works really,
he works at a real interesting pace there.
You know,
it's stunning to watch him go through guys.
Like when he went through Rick story,
I was like,
Jesus Christ.
Like Rick story's a powerful wrestler and when he takes his back and he gets him
in that neck crank and you see the blood squirting out of his nose and like,
Whoa,
yeah,
this is,
this is a heavy fucking squeeze.
This guy has.
And then he did it to Carlos condit.
Um,
who else has done to,
it's not a lot of guys.
He gets a hold of you.
It's just squeezes the life and when it gets on top,
he seems so heavy on Magni when he went and ran through Neil magnate.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just such high level Jujitsu on top.
He's just dad just no air to smushes you.
It's um,
I'm,
I'm such a sucker for a specialist,
whether it's a style vendor specialist was striking specialist or a Damien Maia
specialist.
I love watching the guys that are like at the tip of the,
the ability in whatever the discipline eyes and stop vendor man.
He seems to be getting better every time.
Yeah.
Well for him it was just a v avoiding takedowns like he was so high level as a
kickboxer.
He's so clever.
Like he's,
he's like,
in my opinion,
probably the very best in the sport.
It's setting traps.
Yeah.
He'll,
he'll like gauge you see what you're doing.
They'll switch stances,
getting some information.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not random.
And I liked the way he deals with the take downs.
I mean,
he knows where he's safe and where he's not.
You don't see that he's,
and he's like,
yeah,
it's got a minute that this cook them in it.
But I seen,
I seen what their,
this attempt looks like.
I see what this one looks like walking it through.
All right.
Now my party is going to start.
Yeah.
Here's a guy I talked to one of his guys he trains with um,
I've was referenced in fights in China and uh,
it's one of the guys who trained with a New Zealand and this guy was telling me
so much and show me different things about angles they do and things that they
set up in their striking that I had never knew or thought about.
And this was before I saw him start fighting in the UFC.
You know,
it just,
we have,
everybody was aware of him but he hadn't been in the UFC.
Yeah.
And Man,
these guys,
these guys are really smart.
These,
the techniques like this sport is growing so much,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what I was saying.
Like when you're seeing like really high level,
super technical like him,
like who's a worldclass Labine as good.
He easily could be world champion in many organizations as a kickboxer.
And to see him now in the UFC and seek guys having to deal with that.
It's like wow,
okay,
this is like the Anderson five's a great,
great example.
We'd know how great Anderson is.
Yeah.
And it still looked pretty good against style bender,
but you could see why style bender was special in that fight.
Did he add like another level of trickery?
Yeah.
And I mean and stuff John Jones is doing.
Well so you can't call him a specialist's cause man he does so many different
styles.
Right.
It's like a,
it's really like a Kung Fu movie,
right?
Where he changed styles.
Yeah.
And then they do they do something.
Well John,
such a good kicker too.
I mean that's,
that's interesting that he started out as a wrestler.
Cause like how,
how much of his style now is kicking you.
It's a giant part of his game is utilization of those long ass legs.
Right.
And,
and,
and he's,
and it's interesting like how,
how much time he did.
It looks like he's getting information on that.
Then all of a sudden then when it shifts gears,
it's like,
okay,
I've gotten a lot of information and here's what to do with it.
Yeah.
He's gonna Fight Tiago Santos,
right?
Yeah.
That guy goes for broke.
I mean he goes for broke.
It's interesting to watch him fight because you want to talk about like a,
a wild reckless dude.
Like Santos is dangerous.
Jon Jones should and probably will be a heavy favorite,
but Santos,
he does.
He throws something.
Hey,
make no,
no,
it's going to be,
it's going to be a,
it's a great fight to watch.
Yeah.
That guy's going to go out on his shield.
No,
he and he puts pressure.
I think the interesting thing about,
uh,
well for me,
what's interesting when I watched any of the heavier guys fight is that they
really have to understand where they're safe and whether or not that's something
that John does really good.
How to be in the pocket and the places where he's safe.
And you know,
knowing where he's,
yeah,
he's the best ever at utilizing his reach,
but no one's ever been better at controlling reach.
And then never letting a guy reset.
When guys try to reset,
Bambi kicked some bammy kicks him again.
Bam.
He kicks him again.
And he's like,
he knows when you're trying to get comfortable,
when you're trying to settle in.
And that's when he kicks you like,
it sounds like he senses it.
I just starts battering you like you see?
He's like,
no,
no breaks.
No.
No breaks,
no breaks,
no breaks like the brakes.
What about a man?
Um,
Max Holloway.
Oh Dude.
He's the king of no breaks.
There's no break.
Oh,
Miss Pours it on you.
He's just keeps coming.
Keeps coming.
What happened?
Um,
he pours it on you.
He keeps coming and it's fucking combinations.
Several high profile fighters confirm for UFC two 39 including Michael Cassa
versus Diego Sanchez fight shit.
There's one Michael Kassan pack a lunch,
Bro.
God.
Oh versus dos Santos.
Oh,
Sanchez.
That's it.
That's a great one.
So that's Vegas.
Yeah.
Ooh,
yeah,
that's,
that's good.
Yon Blow.
Hovish verses Luke Rockhold.
That's a great fight to rock holds first fight at light heavyweight.
And you just learn how to say that.
[inaudible] um,
I think I listened to someone else saying,
I just repeated the noise
I had the hardest time with is a beat.
It's a beat.
Magomed Sharp Pauvre oh yeah.
Hard.
Yeah.
That dude who he's nasty.
He's fun to watch.
Yeah.
I did to some nasty shit in there.
So technical.
So Chris,
you know,
and again,
long range.
Yeah.
But can take it to man.
I mean,
he,
he ate some bombs from Jeremy fucking Stevens who's one of the biggest bomb
throwers in the division.
Yeah.
Jeremy has some fucking weapons.
Yeah,
no,
that,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was,
I remember when that fight wasn't high and I was like,
man,
I couldn't wait to watch that.
Yeah.
That was a great fight.
It's close fight to close fight.
I mean,
I think the decision went to is a beat.
Um,
and Jeremy disputed it a little bit,
but I met another close fight.
Very good fight.
But I think the decision was correct,
but the beat is,
um,
you know,
he's had an interesting style.
Right.
Really good grappling.
Crazy trips.
Yeah.
A lot of crazy real old school.
Traditional martial arts kicks,
throws her heel kicks and three 60 roundhouse kicks and shit.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
real,
a lot of great slide.
A lot of balance there.
Yeah.
There's so much talent now.
I mean,
I can't remember a time where there was so many elite high level fighters that
were like so exciting to watch.
There's so many good guys that's like really good guys.
People are slipping through and this sport is growing so much.
And Groin.
Yeah.
Growing all over the world.
Some of these,
like that's one of the cool things about the travel is you get to go see in some
of these,
some of these guys,
some of these athletes and other parts of the world have a huge following and no
one's ever heard of him.
This is one guy.
Uh,
I'm Mary Barra Akbari.
He,
he has I think like almost a million followers on Instagram.
Really?
Yeah.
No Shit.
He's a UFC guy.
No,
no,
no.
That's what I'm saying.
He,
he's the guy who's never fought in the UFC.
Where's he fight?
He fights in a,
uh,
ACA.
No,
Kenton is the Russian organization.
Yeah.
What's it called?
A Aca.
Yeah.
What does it mean?
What does it stand for?
The absolute championship.
ACMA.
Achmad what does Oakmont mean?
I think there is 1.6 million,
but look how handsome he is.
You know,
cause um,
I refereed to fight and iser by genre.
He was at sea.
A heavyweight.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I must see why.
Yeah,
he's a big heavyweight.
Do you think you'd passes a Piss test?
You know,
I'm not living in the man's pocket,
so I don't know if anyone can pass a piss test.
I really don't know.
I really
don't.
That's not something that I'm not an expert on that I leave that impression.
I think he's,
he likes wrestling.
I think a lot of fighters like wrestling right now.
The cm Ronda Rousey make that Cha Ching.
Yeah.
Like,
hmm.
I could do that.
Do you watch pro wrestling?
I've watched occasionally when Tony Hinchcliffe makes me.
Why do you watch it?
No,
no.
Yeah.
I didn't think you would.
I go get it either.
I'm not 14 yeah,
it was.
I loved it.
No,
when I was a kid,
when I realized it was,
I liked it when I was six.
I liked it a lot and I then don't get me wrong,
I don't risk,
not that I don't respect what they're doing.
I used to work at it and notes or Gnocchi Dojo and I did some pro wrestling
workouts with them just to see what they're doing and then taking those bumps
and some of the stuff they would do off to like,
there's no way I will be doing that with my body.
So all respect to it,
but it's just that this doesn't cut me out.
I feel exactly the same way they,
they,
they should be respected as being incredibly tough talent.
Very difficult child.
Yeah.
Athletic,
talented.
The guys that are really good at it that make it look like,
you know,
like art.
Yeah.
I liked Jimmy superfly snicker when I was a kid.
I love that guy.
Yeah.
Bob Backlund.
Remember him?
I don't remember who remember the Iron Sheik of Oh yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
There was some fun times,
but yeah,
I prefer real things.
Yeah.
I mean I get it.
I get the appeal,
you know,
but I,
uh,
I,
that's like,
once you watch really good fights,
it's hard.
It's hard to give a shit about fake fights.
Yeah.
And I just,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't get it.
I didn't know I didn't get it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
But you know what,
some people love it and you know,
that's the thing,
you know,
some people will know every bit of it,
every stick and you know,
I don't know,
but I think there's probably,
you know,
who knows.
I might,
it might catch me cause,
you know,
I'm always trying to get hip to stuff,
so if there's something I don't enjoy,
I like to do it with somebody who enjoys it so I can kind of watch them and kind
of learn how to enjoy it.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Like what's the part that you like about this?
You know what I mean?
Or like I didn't listen to a lot of country music,
but then,
um,
I will,
I used to work with glad,
either challenge a lot and Ted Williams was like,
you don't like country music.
So he gave me country music education.
What's the matter?
What you don't like?
Tell him you can see the same good music.
And then I was like,
okay.
Hey,
I got you.
What did you get into?
Uh,
well I started when I started grabbing it.
I liked the old stuff.
I like boot cut.
I like 'em Moreau.
I like Kris Kristofferson Sunday morning coming down.
Yeah.
And I like your boy.
Your boy was on your were sturgeon.
Yeah.
Sturge will I like stores.
That's it is deep.
Right?
He's a bad motherfucker I seeking Jesus play with.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah,
he's legit.
That that song is a well written song,
man,
that he's a trip of a story man.
He was like working regular jobs working on and his
wife told him he could make a living doing music.
She's like,
you know,
you don't suck at this.
So she told him to go for it and now he's like one of the biggest music artists
in the world.
Right,
right.
It's crazy.
And it didn't take long either,
man.
Yeah,
that,
that turtles all the way down like that.
So that's a really cool song.
First Time,
first time I met him,
like almost immediately after meeting them we got high as fuck and to the
podcast
we loo barbecued.
It's been a couple of times where,
you know,
he called me up after the podcast,
so it was like,
man,
I didn't even know what the fuck we were talking about for the first 20 minutes
because we were so high.
Because if you live in Nashville like,
and he lives in the Nashville area,
you go out there and get the weed,
they have pretty good weed.
It's okay,
but it's not California.
We'd like California where you'd,
it's preposterous.
Right?
Right.
If you're not used to that stuff and you smoke that shit and try to be on air,
like all of a sudden now you're on a podcast or on air.
And we were talking about like,
yeah,
I don't think I could keep up.
I was like,
I can,
can you keep up with a joy?
No.
I went on his podcast,
man,
and he packed enough,
I think they'd get a village high pick.
He put it in this,
this bowl is like,
and just tore it up,
emptied out,
did it again.
And then eight a gummy bear and was like,
I started putting on pink Floyd.
He's a real deal man.
You know?
I mean he's free.
Joey Diaz is free.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm not that free man.
I'm not that free.
I wish I could be.
I,
you know,
and I have,
I have,
I have respect for it.
Just be like you said that freeness yeah,
a lot of people were free.
Yeah.
But I'm not as pretty like,
I think your boys,
lot of your,
your people seem kind of free.
Like who?
I think Eddie Bravo seems for you and he's a free thinker man.
Yeah.
And others.
Yeah know Eddie's a,
that's why his Jujitsu so creative.
He's,
he's,
he's so open to ideas,
you know?
I mean he's,
he's also like,
he doesn't like losing,
so he's like,
he's like,
oh no,
I'm going to figure out how to win.
I'm going to figure how to beat this.
So he'll look con con like he'll like look at a position and he'll have some
weird unorthodox take on how to get to a better spot or how to control the
position better or how to finish from there.
And they're like,
you'll see like damn,
like his,
he's just everything.
You know,
if you have a conversation with him about,
about stuff and he is,
you'll learn a lot just from every time like,
okay,
I know you did.
You got to take away something from him.
Dude.
He's,
I can't do one of the bits that he's doing,
but he's,
he's doing stand up now and some of this shit is really fucking funny,
man.
He made me laugh really hard last night.
Really.
I would have to do the bit,
I would have to tell you the bit to show you I've been so when he does stand it.
Yeah I seen him on salt so I should go stay funny man.
It's getting really fun.
It's getting more and more comfortable doing it.
He was always funny.
I mean he always used to make me laugh but a,
he tried it way back in the day.
He tried stand up many,
many,
many moons
ago.
Like fucking 2003 or four or something like that.
He tried and it just wasn't for him.
He was too busy with other stuff.
He just,
he tried,
he was going to try it and then get good at it.
But he got,
he bombed a few times.
He's like fuck this.
And then he tried it again,
I want to say like four years ago.
Was it about that three years ago,
four years ago,
somewhere in that range.
And uh,
he's been doing it steady since.
He's actually pretty funny man.
Like,
like,
like made me laugh like really loud.
Yeah.
Cause I've seen it on social media that you guys have some shows where like he's
on there.
You are on it a bunch of,
yeah.
That's how Sam Tripoli's shows.
Yeah.
A lot of Sam shows.
He does a,
a podcast,
tinfoil hat podcast with Sam and uh,
we're all real good friends.
And Sam is also a conspiracy nut.
So they get together and talk about the Illuminati and shit.
Yeah,
I have friends like that.
I remember.
Yeah.
I go back and forth with conspiracies.
I have a love hate relationship with conspiracies.
I love some of them.
Some of them are fascinating.
Some of them like,
okay,
what the fuck happened there?
You know?
But,
and then some of them like,
I can't do this anymore.
Yeah,
I didn't when I was younger I used to think about it.
But then I think when I had a kid at,
well yeah,
I don't have time for that.
No time for nonsense and becomes very precious.
Becomes food.
How exactly not over here worrying about the fucking Illuminati.
I don't even know what that means.
What's the Illuminati?
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm busy.
I kind of go,
but I get how people get sucked into that rabbit hole.
No,
no,
no.
I could see it.
I went into a rabbit hole the other day,
but with aliens,
I watched three alien documentaries in a row.
I Rotch to this one on Bob Lasar who was a guy who claims that he worked at area
51 it's very compelling.
Very interesting.
Because at the top of us and when he would suggest yes,
that's the one I would suggest.
It's called area 51 you.
Oh,
Bob was our area 51 and flying saucers,
I think it's called.
It's on iTunes.
It's fucking good.
Take notes because there's some things that this guy knew that it's almost
certain that he worked where he said he worked did he worked at area 51 the
question becomes,
he told all the truth about all these things that have since been proven to be
true.
Um,
weird.
So he gave,
he gave first cut at those truths,
right?
Yeah,
long time ago too.
He came out about this like 30 years ago.
There was a Nevada tell her about this bibles or he would,
he would.
He was worried about his life.
Here's what happened.
Apparently the guy was working in this area doing research for whatever the
government wanted him to do at area 51 what he did there,
who knows,
he gets fired from this job and then takes his friends to this viewing position
in the mountains where they can see them flying,
flying saucers.
He was telling them they fly them out of this base.
I'm going to bring,
you guys were going to watch it.
He,
they videotape this on old school VHS tape.
You can see these flying saucers flying around area 51 and he says,
these are not not being piloted by a,
by aliens.
These are being piloted by human beings,
but that these are real devices.
These things are real.
There are,
it's a real vehicle and they got this real vehicle from some other,
some other civilization from somewhere in space and they had nine of them.
It sounds like total horse shit when you hear it,
but then you watch the video and so the questions come like how did he know that
they were going to be flying these things up there?
How do you know they were going to do them on Wednesdays?
How did he know where to where he could see it?
How did he know?
How did he know about the biometric data?
How did he know about element one 15 he was talking about this element,
this manmade element that it's a real element that they've now identified,
but when he was talking about it in 1980 no one knew what the fuck he was
talking about.
Our 1984 whatever it was,
when he was,
when he first got interviewed about this.
So when this guy is bringing this stuff up today and people are looking back at
all the different things that he said that have since been proven to be true,
especially the existence of area 51,
the,
the government had to,
at some point in time in the 90s,
they had to say that they own the base and say that it did,
did in fact exist so that they could broaden the,
uh,
top secret area or the,
you know,
like there's a do not enter zone or they'll pull you over and arrest you if you
get past a certain spot.
They wanted to broaden that area so people couldn't be watching their crafts fly
around like Bob Lasar was.
And when they did that,
when they expanded the territory,
that's when they had to actually admit that the base was real.
So he was proven to be correct on so many different things that he said.
Like he explained how they get them out there,
explain what their research was and he said that they had these things that run
on some,
they manipulate gravity in some way and they're very small because these aliens
are very small little creatures.
Like a child,
like a eight 10 year old child.
It makes you go,
what the fuck man?
Like I said,
he talked about,
he said,
well he saw them,
he knew how they operated.
Wow.
The things that he knows that are true,
that that turned out to be true,
that how could he have known them if he didn't work at area 51 of the most
compelling aspects of it and the fact that area 51 was at one point in time by
the governments take it didn't exist and then it was like a legend.
And this was when he was talking about it.
And so watching this documentary and seeing this guy 30 years later,
still basically saying exactly the same thing,
but with a bunch of things have been proved.
Have improvement.
Cynthia.
Yeah,
that is intense.
It's a trip,
man.
I mean if the government really did at one point in time have some craft that it
got from another planet,
what the fuck man.
But the thing is,
how would we take that?
How do you think people would take that if they found out?
How do you think they'd handle that?
If they really knew there was something that was so sophisticated that it can
visit us from another planet.
It could be here in minutes,
land of the White House lawn and do whatever the fuck it wanted to.
You couldn't even shoot it.
Right.
Bullets.
How would people take that?
I think that people would just keep going on like with every other scare.
I think so,
yeah.
I think,
okay,
there's um,
there could be a media that's supposed to hit us.
Right,
right.
I mean,
how do people take it?
that's what they're saying.
I think it could happen.
I think it would be a fuck fest in the streets.
Yeah.
What they say they say could happen.
I mean,
you know,
if he's saw one common yeah,
but I'm saying that if you saw one company,
because you don't see the alien coming,
if people realize,
yeah,
these guys could show up.
Right.
I don't know.
I remember the conspiracy that,
um,
what I,
I remember I did remember that,
remember that when they would be like these booklets of like xerox stuff going
on,
like the one about aids and stuff like that.
Maybe that one.
Yeah.
That one had been gone for awhile.
The can,
the aids conspiracy doctors correctors memorandum.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
People used to hand those out.
Right.
Try and tell people that aids was a hoax,
not a hoax.
That it was like all this stuff memorized.
Got a government conspiracy.
Yeah.
That has one way out.
For a while,
I remember I was video,
I was,
maybe I was making copies and passing along guy that blew my mind.
Well,
there was a
one doctor at one point in time that was trying to say that,
that HIV does not cause aids and we had them on way back in the day.
Early on was that guy's name
Duesberg?
Dr Peter Duesberg?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what it is or am I just remembered it.
He is a professor at the University of California,
Berkeley I believe.
I think he's a Bot biologist and his take was that HIV does not cause aids.
That what causes AIDS is a compromised immune system and the HIV is actually a
weak virus and it shows up in the immune systems of people that are already
compromised.
That's why you're finding it in these people that it's not the cause of their
immune system being confidant compromise.
It's a symptom of it and that with these people are really dying from is there
their whole system being fucked up by drugs that either they're taking AZT,
which destroys their body.
You know,
it was a cancer medication,
like a chemotherapy that was so powerful is killing people quicker than the
cancer was and then they switched it over to using it with people that had aids
because in in the early days they would call aids the gay cancer.
Right,
right.
There was all these different,
like they were trying to figure out what it was and what it did.
And early on this guy was saying this and we had them on the podcast and people
got so mad there,
there were so mad that given this guy a platform to spread his,
his propaganda and his lies.
And I was like,
wow.
But he is a professor,
he has done like legitimate cancer research.
He's,
you know,
I mean,
don't you want to listen to them?
And,
and I,
I wanted to get someone on debate him,
but nobody wanted to debate him.
It was like trying to get someone to debate a Holocaust denier.
I can,
nobody wants to give them the platform and what he wants you to talk to him,
which I understand.
But those,
those kinds of,
I mean it's very highly unlikely that all these doctors are incorrect and her
hiding the fact that HIV,
you know,
and then now the fact that they've got these,
um,
HIV medications,
it basically,
they can take people and make them HIV negative now.
Right.
Didn't they have like a couple people have tested HIV negative after
medications?
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I'm too stupid.
Too stupid to understand what's really going on.
That's for me that I know that I'm like,
when I watched some of those things,
you know,
they,
some of them they like lead off with these statements and we all know and we
know this.
I'm like,
I don't,
I don't know.
Yeah.
There's too much to know.
How do we get in the subject of AIDS?
I don't know.
We're talking about conspiracy theories.
Oh yeah.
That was the one that I,
I that one,
that one when it was out back in what?
[inaudible] 89 or [inaudible] 88 when those little pamphlets are going around.
Yeah.
I was like,
yeah,
well marijuana and conspiracies go together like cookies and milk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's nothing like we that starts your,
your gears turning and you started thinking that's where a lot of people start
thinking conspiracies are against them too.
All right.
You get high and they start thinking of the world's closing in on you.
Everybody's watching you.
Surveillance.
But do you don't probably don't feel like that when you get high.
No,
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do.
Sometimes I kind of like it though.
You know why I like it?
Cause it ends and when it ends you feel great.
It's almost like a brutal brain workout.
Like you,
you'd go digging deep into your psyche and find out all the things you're scared
of.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
it's like it's work.
Yeah.
It's working.
Get a little work.
He like took a look at you say,
well,
you know,
I never thought about me from that angle before.
Yeah.
I like to do it.
I'm going to clean up mine.
Yeah.
Clean up your shit.
Especially if you're,
I think if you're in a high pressure job and you're very busy like I am,
I think those,
those little insights are very important because you could get caught up in your
own bullshit and what you're trying to do and not think of the impact you're
having on the people that are around you.
Right?
Yeah.
And then,
then that marijuana goes,
hey,
wow.
Yeah.
And you impact a lot of people.
Too many people,
especially with,
you know,
like you know,
cause I would have things where like in my philosophy might change or a little
thing and you're talking to a lot of people and like,
oh I don't know if I feel like that anymore.
Yeah,
yeah.
You could switch,
right?
Yeah.
You could definitely switch her opinions.
I do.
I switch my opinions.
I do too.
Yeah.
Well I don't know if there was anything wrong with that either.
And I think everybody should be more flexible with their opinion.
I mean obviously there's opinions like rape is bad,
don't murder people don't steal.
Obviously those things,
normal stuff that everybody agrees on.
But then you get to a certain point and I think we get real married to the idea
of our being right and we get real married to the idea of winning an argument
with our opinions.
I think that's when things get kind of squirrely because then you start trying
to calculate an argument to make your position sound better rather than
considering your position for what it really is.
And then also being just try and,
yeah,
always trying to figure out and learn a little something.
Take something away from it.
Not to be a knee jerk.
That's the thing.
You don't want to be a knee jerk.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
You know what I want,
I went real,
uh,
back and forth on pretty recently is a universal basic income.
And I see this guy that uh,
a universal bank.
Yeah.
Andrew,
yeah.
Yeah.
These running for president down platform.
That's part of his platform.
Right,
right.
And uh,
I had him on the podcast,
really enjoyed talking to him.
Really,
really smart guy.
Very cool guy.
Um,
but when I'm talking to him and I'm thinking about it,
I'm like,
boy,
I don't even know if that's enough.
Like what,
what they're doing,
the idea behind it.
Like the idea is that automation's going to take all these jobs,
automated cars going to style.
It means it's going to like wipe out a shit load of jobs apparently.
And the idea is that if we don't have some form of universal basic income,
there's going to be chaos,
but having just some amount of money.
So that people have their needs taken care of.
You always have food.
You always have shelter.
This you're taking care of now go pursue your happiness.
The,
the real problem with that though was who was it that we had the other day where
we were talking about um,
meaning about people.
One was it
okay
Nick Christakis is that it was people find meaning in their life.
Who was that might be him.
I don't recall it but don't think it was,
I think it was someone else.
Was it Ben Shapiro?
No,
I don't think it was,
but anyway,
whoever it was that we were talking about it,
we were saying that.
Does that give people a sense of meaning though?
Because people like,
like you for instance,
you,
you know your responsibility as a referee.
You know how significant it is.
You know,
you one of the best in the world when you're refereeing a high level
championship bout when the fighters find out that herb dean's a referee,
they get excited like a good one less thing I have to think about.
It's like you're,
you're,
you're putting so much of who you are into that job.
Do we know?
I'm looking for a piece of it.
I don't know yet.
Sorry.
No worries.
But I mean,
look,
that's,
that's gigantic,
right?
I mean,
that's,
I know for you that that's,
you take that very seriously.
Yeah.
All right.
Maybe I guess talking about it was it?
No,
I don't think so.
Anyway.
You have meaning,
you know,
and what you do if you just got money to lay around and someone said,
well,
just go pursue your goals.
Okay.
But I think what people really like to do when the really happy is make a living
doing something that has meaning,
but getting them to them.
I don't know if it would
smooth things out if you just gave people money.
Yeah.
I don't know how that would work.
I don't know how,
I don't dare that when I saw him,
what he's talking about and I don't,
I don't like that one.
That's,
I'm not smart enough for that one to know how that's going to work.
But he seemed to think that there was a lot of ancillary benefits,
like things like he lowered crime rates lowered,
you know that you would have lowered instances of disease,
lowered instances of people that were injured doing certain things.
Like if you had money and you made sure that people had a certain amount of
money,
it actually might cost the public less money.
I could,
I could see where he would come from with that because I think there's
something,
cause there's there,
there's a lot of people are probably met a lot of people who say that money
isn't everything and there's these things that mean this,
but it's only once you get enough money where you can step off the off the
little hamster wheel,
the hamster wheel for a second to like start,
uh,
thinking about these other things.
Yeah.
Money's overwhelming,
man.
Yeah.
I mean if you don't have it,
it's over.
I remember when I first got a development deal when I was doing standup and I
got a big check and I just immediately felt like,
oh,
like literally like a weight was lifted off my back.
Just a weight,
like I had a weight vest on.
I took it off.
Like now I don't have to worry about food or rent or gas or anything for like at
least a year.
Right,
right.
And I was like,
I don't know how to think about it.
And then I remember,
I think it God,
it feels so free.
It feels so different because most people's lives who are in debt,
most of the time they're there.
They have this constant fog of pressure.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's around them about those pills.
Those God damn bills are always there.
It's creeping on you.
And then you get credit cards and your Max.
Those motherfuckers out still trying to live these dreams that people are given
to you,
that you're supposed to have these like,
you know,
the symbols,
the status,
you know,
people trying to go like it's really,
and that's even weird because you know,
I'm not really into that stuff.
But then again,
I'm on television,
so I guess I can forward that to me.
I don't know.
Maybe that's why I like to think of them deep yet.
No,
I don't need a Mercedes man.
I'm just,
you know,
I would just drive it.
You're just driving my car and my 2005,
you know,
that's,
I just need to get from point a to point B.
But you know,
maybe that's why,
I don't know.
I don't know man.
You said you have a 74 bronco too,
so you must appreciate.
Cool.
She did.
See that's what I'm saying.
But that's the thing.
I was about to get rid of it.
And my friend said,
cause I was like,
man,
it doesn't mean what it used to mean to me,
but I do appreciate it.
And now I'm like my friends like,
Hey,
I'm going to hook,
we're going to hook this thing up.
Ah.
So I was like,
all right,
I sent it to him.
He says,
I'm going to give you a deal.
We're going to get it all hooked up.
Right.
And uh,
but it does,
I've will admit that like before,
it meant a lot more to me than it does now.
Kevin Hart came over here with a bronco the other day and I saw his bronco.
Here's a red one.
His is better than mine.
Yours,
this tube,
his his dope.
His makes me realize how cool the convertibles are when they're,
they're done as convertibles.
Like he's just driving around with no top on.
I'm like,
aw,
that's so nice.
That's what,
that's how I'm doing mine.
Because I had gotten mine as a convertible and I wouldn't,
yeah,
I got a top cause I want to do a hard top on it.
But if you're taking it on and off,
that is,
that is a nasty bronco.
You know,
he has his own car company that does this shit.
He does this shit with his own company.
He's got like a hundred businesses dude.
I never met anybody as motivational or motivated as Kevin Hart.
No,
I saw the,
I saw I,
I follow him on social media and that man is Yay.
And I saw what he was talking about,
you know,
talking to you about too.
Yeah.
He's,
he's very motivated.
He's the most authentically positive person I think I've ever met.
And look at that.
He's got an Eleanor Mustang.
That's a fucking beast,
man.
They made that at his place too.
So he has his own fucking car place that makes him cars.
Look at that.
I mean the two,
it's off the charts,
but more importantly,
look his outlook,
like his,
his healthy positive outlook and the way,
you know,
he just goes through life.
It's very inspirational to us all that it's very positive,
uplifting.
Like he saw that he was trying to help people and all these different facets of
life help people with financial advice,
help with motivation to help people to get the bullshit out of their life,
get the clutter out of their life.
Yeah.
No,
I,
uh,
I even like when I first started really liking it was when he was,
doing that thing where he was meeting up with people to run the ad.
I was like,
man,
I like that.
I going like that as much as I travel.
And I used to like to run,
you know?
Well,
you could always do that.
Other people do that.
My friend Cameron Hanes does that all the time.
He'll invite people to run with him places.
Yeah.
My thing with the yoga is I've been decided to do it when I'm on the road,
so that's been cool.
Is I got to do it.
And um,
you're going to Atlanta this weekend?
No,
no,
no.
But what the fuck does two,
not one,
two world championship fights.
Damn.
You didn't get invited to Atlanta.
Are they gonna use Atlanta guys?
I'm not sure,
but there's good Atlanta guy,
a referee.
Blake Grice.
Yeah,
he's a good guy.
Um,
there's um,
isn't that Matt Grice's a brother hazy?
I didn't know that.
I don't,
I think one of the referee,
he's,
what's his name?
Who's old?
So sometimes they use,
what's your memory of that fighter?
Uh,
he used to have the black dude with a,
like a patch of gray here,
but that like a strict is it makes it here look real cool.
What's his name is?
Um,
there's a really good fighter.
Uh,
his son fights him.
It may now.
He came from a kickboxing background.
I don't know why I'm drawing a blank on his name.
This is embarrassing because it's embarrassing because he's going to be mad at
me like,
like you don't know me.
I know him.
He fill it old right now.
All right.
That's the weed hanging out with Joey Diaz will fuck your head.
I'm couple months.
Joey's podcasts.
No,
it was like,
it was probably a couple of years ago.
Oh,
okay.
But it was fun.
I'm recovered.
I'm saying.
Yeah Dude.
He,
he'll change your life over in that weird room.
It gives people those stars a death.
I know you have 250 milligrams of THC.
That's crazy.
250 milligrams.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That is a crazy amount.
Yeah.
That's not right.
No,
no,
it's fine.
I'm still trying to think of this guy's name.
Yeah,
I know you are trying to jostle your memory in some way.
We'll come back.
We'll come back to it.
Yeah.
Um,
there's a lot of guys who,
uh,
our former fighters that,
that I think frank Triggs doing referee work now,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Frank Triggs.
Really good.
I would like more guys do that and I would,
I would love to have more former fighters.
Be Judges,
you know,
who I saw who was really good,
uh,
who came and took my course is um,
Chris Liebing.
Yeah.
[inaudible] good referee.
While he's doing,
he's been doing stuff in Camo and he's,
he's coming along.
He's doing it.
Yeah.
Nice.
He just won in a bare knuckle boxing.
I saw,
I saw some clips.
I'll bet it was.
Yeah.
I mean it does look good.
Well it's good for him with his style,
his crazy style.
That's a,
that's actually a great move for him,
you know.
But he retired from finding cause he didn't want to fight anymore.
I mean he just,
but I guess a little bit of time off and he's like,
fuck it.
You know,
there was two organizations that used to be a different bare knuckle boxing,
but they went under and when they went under they owe him like 90,000.
Yeah.
They cheated.
They,
oh yeah.
That's rough in his recourses.
Just let people know.
Yeah,
these guys owe me money.
Did you see the clip that uh,
um,
uh,
Crooklyn from a Kirkland on,
on Twitter put up of I'm the owner of bare knuckle boxing saying that a fighter
didn't fight hard enough.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah.
I um,
and,
and he was proud of it.
He's like,
this is the way we do it.
See if you can find her tweet.
Yeah.
This is the way we do it.
This is what you can,
hey.
Yeah,
that was ridiculous.
And you're just going to a guys pay.
Yeah.
So he's getting it took 50% of his money cause it didn't meet.
Cause it didn't meet his standards.
Yeah.
I just,
I want him when he said did the crowd chair that I sorry.
I hope not.
I'd hate to see that some of the crowd could cheer for it to the president.
I'll up bare knuckle fighting.
Was it as Mr. David Feldman,
he looks,
he's on coke.
Look at them.
At least
I'll see you guys having fun tonight.
Make some noise.
No fighting KP.
A tip as a brand new sport in a brand new company and we're here for action.
And we want action and we demand action from the fighter.
The man didn't get accident that last quite could rusty crowd or one of the run.
Therefore he's given a half this Perth to Reggie Barnett make some noise blocks.
He,
this is how we do it.
A bear
you fight or you don't get paid.
That's not good.
It's not good that he thinks the Zombie Prophet wrote this can't be legal.
He was,
see what Stephie Hayes wrote?
Uh,
Crooklyn MMA.
How that works.
She's lucky if she wrote what the actual fuck is this hillbilly?
The whole chair?
Uh,
yeah.
I concur.
What in the actual fuck is that hillbilly bullshit?
The now I'm pride.
They used to dock,
right?
The yellow car was a yellow card.
Is a penalty penalty for being boring.
Most of them were.
Yeah.
And sometimes irresponsibly.
I,
I've watched some of those yellow cards.
I'm like,
you crazy.
You crazy.
Take that back.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You gave that guy a yellow car.
He can't fight me harder.
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
We can't engage.
He's going to get lit up and these,
this moments we have to try to figure out what the fuck to do.
You're on the outside to try to figure out how to get in and you getting lit and
then the ref is like caught fight,
fight and you're like,
but in Asia,
at some of them they like,
some of them are,
I used to work a lot at this Korean shell and they changed their figuring out
their style.
But man,
when I first got to,
they're like,
um,
so there's a yellow card.
Any backward step backstep any backstep you should,
we move on to you to give a yellow card.
And I was like,
Leo Machida would never make any money.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't know if I can do it that I don't think that's,
I mean you invited me over here for a reason.
I'm,
I'm just going to do what I do and hope you bring me back.
But I don't know if I can do that.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Do.
Do you ever go to a place and the commissions or a promoter will tell you,
hey,
fights,
go to the ground.
I want you to give it just a couple of seconds and stand them up.
I go places and people telling me what to do all the time and I'm not going to
do it because we came at the end of the day.
No one's going to know that you told me to do it.
It's going to be me doing it 100%.
Yeah.
So I'm going to,
um,
yeah,
I can't,
I can't.
Um,
yeah.
Basically.
So glad you just said it that way too.
Cause that's,
that's,
people need to get that in their head because I know that sometimes people do
get affected by whether they want to please a promoter or please a crowd or,
and they're not doing the right thing.
It's such a tremendous responsibility.
Yeah.
You're going to be,
but you're the one who's going to be a,
for some of those choices,
you know,
those choices that they made,
they're making those choices with your name,
so yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's yeah,
like the backstep Kevin Johnson answering the guy,
but this is a tweet from that bare knuckle fc.
Okay.
Kevin Johnson.
No money was taken from any fighters.
That statement did exactly what it's supposed to,
what it was supposed it didn't say to suppose and lit a fire under every single
fighters ass from that point on giving you one of the greatest fights you'll
ever see.
No,
no,
no.
Those guys fought that way because that's who the fuck they are.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
there's no,
I had nothing to do with that.
Jason Knight and autumn low ball fight.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can't,
you can't claim credit for a hint for Jason Knight doing what he did.
They are the low ball fuck outta here.
They would fight that way in a fucking Walmart parking lot.
That's how those guys would fight every time they fight there.
Jason Knight is the both those dudes animals.
Those dudes are so tough.
Jason Knight has my favorite nickname.
Hick Diaz.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like a bad mother fucker.
He's a bad motherfucker that,
but it was tough looking at their faces after the fight.
I was like,
man,
I might have to rethink my position on,
on bare knuckle fights.
Look at their faces afterwards.
Yeah.
I mean that is crazy.
You know,
it's a lifetime of cuts all over the,
if I'm looking at is,
is right under his nose.
That's
crazy.
Cut Man.
He stitched,
stitched the fuck up all over the place.
That is rough man.
His whole face got lacerated.
I mean that is a lot of cuts.
Yeah.
That's more like a Moyie Thai fight and it really makes you think,
but I can,
um,
that's got to be the most brutal,
right?
More time.
Yeah,
I believe so.
Mostly type bare knuckle would be like,
what do they call it?
Left way where they just stay.
They kind of like wrap the hands up and a hand wrap.
Yeah.
It's not bare knuckle,
but it's um,
I think a bare,
bare knuckle moitai would be the hardest.
But the thing what a,
my argument was always,
and it still remains this,
that if you're not going to pad anything else,
like you're not going to pad the shins,
you're not going to bad the knees,
are they all both?
Why are you patting the knuckles?
You're just giving people a false sense of security in terms of what is actually
effective.
We don't want,
we don't want to practice something that doesn't really work if you don't have
gloves on.
Right.
I mean,
if every time you punch someone,
you don't have gloves on,
your hand would break.
And we do.
Okay.
We clearly can't punch people.
It's stupid.
You got to use elbows and knees and you gotta do something.
Right,
right,
right.
So in order to fight with your knuckles as much as UFC fighters do,
you pat everything you pad,
you put raps,
you put padding over it.
Boxing is like,
it's a different world.
As soon as you take gloves off,
Punches get in that you can't block it.
It's way more consequence.
A lot of more cuts.
But at least if now we know what actually works.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
I wasn't thinking about it from that point of view.
Yeah,
that has given people,
people were thinking that,
ah,
yeah,
you're right.
Like people would think that boxing well before him May,
may everything.
It was the most effective way of doing things.
But then when you a MMA is a whole different,
the size of the boxing
glove of the techniques you can do and what you can't do and what's gonna work
and what's not going to work.
It's,
it's supposed to be the sport of fighting and you've basically brought it down
to a raw form,
but you're still covering the knuckles and padding the knuckles just because of
perception and see the problem with that guy,
this bare knuckle boxing guy when he says some stupid shit like that is that it
reinforces what people don't like about combat sports.
What people don't like about the idea of bare knuckle boxing,
that it's brutal and it's just there for chaos and write,
write,
come for action.
We're here to see action.
That guy's people think that about him.
He May.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and I don't think that,
um,
I don't think that a MMA athletes,
I think a MMA athletes I think are the most honorable and,
uh,
well behaved and you know,
not because of fear anything because of what the sport is.
Yeah.
You can get it out of like,
I mean,
people they know event,
you know,
that they're,
it could,
because our aggressive nature is being put in a channeled,
channeled in a,
in an organized way to make sense.
I'll tell you one of the most aggressive,
I run around the Rose Bowl.
When I see the Peloton come around,
that's when the most aggressive things I've seen men,
those dudes are constantly cursing each other out and curse and everybody else
out,
a little soccer moms out there trying to run around the rose bowl.
But the guys,
the man,
oh,
but the guy's throwing punches or never,
you know,
cursing people out.
So the runners,
no,
no.
What do you mean?
What's a Peloton as the guys on the bikes?
But isn't that like,
Oh,
I thought Peloton u stands still.
I don't know.
I was making it,
I'm not talking,
I'm talking about the guys at the Rose Bowl.
It's really,
know what I'm saying.
They'll come,
they'll train there.
Oh,
when they come out and they train with a riding stationary bikes riding
together,
the riding together and they're out there racing.
No,
their,
their training and then there's some aggressive,
those dudes are aggressive because they're cutting each other off and shins.
And maybe just maybe just to follow the rules.
Right.
Or just the,
there's the word Peloton,
which means a group of cyclists.
It's not the same as,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
okay.
So the cyclist cows on based off of it,
cause I didn't think I'd use the word [inaudible].
I was like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I thought I used a big word and make a mistake.
I'll go to,
okay.
All right.
Okay.
So these people,
they're racing and they're cussing each other out.
They're training.
Oh,
so not racing.
They just trained together on the [inaudible] training.
And again,
that's at the Rose Bowl.
Okay.
You've been to the rose bowl,
right.
You know the,
the,
there's a running loop.
You go in and you can get it in five k around it.
Like,
yeah,
those dudes are intense.
Really way more intense than I see our athlete tactics.
Well because there's not as much consequences.
Right.
You know,
they're not going to get off the pike,
compete each other's asses,
talk shit.
Really.
I bet they are.
Well it's like one time I wish one of them would have come back and then he said
it's like road rage.
Right?
You get road ragey when you're in your car.
I was like,
your workout done.
Don't do another lap
looking for you.
That's at the Rose Bowl.
Oh,
okay.
And so they get mad at each other cause they're trying to past tense.
It's like it's aggressive maybe cause there's some rules to it I think.
I think there's like probably way here,
there's probably a lot of structure as to riding in a pack like that.
Right.
And then also they're trying to get their workout in and they're on the,
and the,
and then there's other people out there trying to do other stuff and they're
really serious about there's,
I mean,
you know,
it's aggressive.
Maybe I,
maybe it's just shocking to me because it doesn't look like it would be that
aggressive.
Because when you think about fighters,
like especially guys even training together,
it's rare that they swear at each other.
Talk Shit to me.
Like if two guys get in an argument,
like if someone,
a guy doesn't let go,
somebody tapped and people scream or something like that.
Yeah.
And so that's the other thing.
I think that's why the respect has,
because there'd be get better.
You have to put yourself in situations where you're going to have,
where you're going to be at a disadvantage and vulnerable.
And so you have to trust your training partners to have this level of respect
and you're going to have to reciprocate that with things like leg locks.
Yes,
exactly.
You gotta be really careful to let go quick and man,
this leg lock game that people are doing now.
Today,
I need to learn it.
I don't know.
Yeah.
See that's the thing.
I know,
I used to think I was good at like Luxe and uh,
these days.
So simple.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And,
and then,
uh,
I guess because,
you know,
I guess it wouldn't take much to do,
we get a leg locks,
you just have to be willing to do them back in the day.
Right.
Everybody else was like,
no,
no.
It's the,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
but he used to be like a simple setup.
Yeah.
You dive in the heel,
Hook Taiwan,
a toe hold now.
Yeah.
Very intense.
And do so other studios,
so some people were getting it,
they were doing other things.
Yeah.
Like maybe the way they hide their feet are the way they do this kind of say
that the first guy in modern MMA that started really wrecking people with leg
locks with MNR.
Yeah.
And then Paul Harris,
who MNR and Paul Harris,
those are the two guys.
I remember George Greer Gel.
He fought him and ran him and I ripped his fucking knee apartment.
And you know,
Kurt Chels,
a Brazilian Jujitsu Brown,
he was a very early in the fight him.
He just did that Amun Ra role,
just dove on the knee and next thing you know,
he's got you in a fucking inverted,
he'll hook.
And then Paul,
Horace,
anything,
he,
you can't defend this.
Like he's too strong.
He's too strong.
So he can do,
he can do and ways build.
He can do a lot of stuff that just doesn't make sense.
I remember we had that guy against the cage on a single this like nobody's
worried about it.
He'll have a leg lock from there.
Boom.
Inverted those legs,
grab him.
You're not going anywhere.
Yeah.
He was devastating.
He didn't let go and he would really,
really mangle your fucking knee.
Right?
Yeah.
So like that's when like,
I remember when they,
uh,
cause I,
I got the referee him,
uh,
in Brazil before he was doing a lot in the UFC.
And so I kind of seen him and like a,
I think one of the might've been a tournament format and I've never had any
problem.
But um,
you know,
he usually,
he stopped when I told him to,
you know,
but other than that one fight of from,
I think it was from Brazil or he's got some money in a leg lock and he's not
letting go and,
and,
and I think it's a leg lock,
see if he could find it.
But it's a,
it's an early fight in his crib,
but it's crazy.
Like they're like trying to pull him off the guy and he's not letting her know
like a,
like a pit bull.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
He's so strong,
so strong.
And apparently his upbringing was horrific.
Yeah.
Like I heard he had a tough,
he's like,
you know,
it's weird.
It's like,
cause you see that behavior and I only see him,
he seems like he,
you know,
some people have a cool energy when they're just around.
Yeah.
It always makes me smile when I see.
But I don't smile when I see that.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
But he's one of those guys that's like soft spoken,
easy going.
Yeah.
I think something happens to that guy when he engages,
you know,
when you're in locked in mortal combat,
he becomes just pure savage.
Yeah.
And He,
I mean,
he does leg locks that no one else does because no one else is strong enough to
do,
to have those legs that just when he,
you know what I mean?
He doesn't care if both legs or their arms in there anything to it.
It's all crap.
It's all getting trash compacted,
you know?
Um,
he had a very interesting grappling match with Gary Tonin.
Did you ever see that?
I did see that.
Yeah,
I did.
I saw some clips of it,
like some bits of it.
Yeah.
It really shows you how good Gary,
Tony,
yeah.
He's,
because Paul Harris is so much bigger than him.
I mean,
he's probably 40,
50 pounds heavier than him.
He's much bigger than him,
you know,
and um,
to watch those guys go back and forth,
it was really,
really interesting.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
Tony,
like he's,
he can,
and he's one of those people who can get,
you know,
you get a position,
but it's still just so hard to,
so he can just move away,
you know?
Well,
his grappling so elite and he's getting really good at striking now too.
And he's really dedicated to MMA and he's undefeated.
He's been fighting in one FC,
which I'm excited.
I'm very excited about one FC.
I love what they're doing.
I love the attitude that they're taking of making it about respect and martial
arts and bringing it to like some old school martial arts values.
They're fucking gigantic right now in Asia.
They put on great fights and they have the best fighter in the world.
They have Demetrius mighty mouse.
John,
what's really is what's really cool is because there's a lot of guys in Asia who
were really exciting to watch at that weight.
So it's kind of exciting to see him get over there with all these guys that,
that's,
I'm really excited about it.
Well,
he got tested in his first fight.
I mean he won by submission,
but he got tested and um,
uh,
Alvar has got stopped by that Russian dude.
Timothy.
What?
His,
his,
uh,
his last name,
the guy that stopped a Goddamn,
and I forget his name,
he got stopped.
Eddie Alvarez.
Timothy.
It's Timothy.
Not Timothy.
It's some strange Russian name.
Timothy.
No,
I don't remember his last name.
But anyway,
he's a beast.
That's the UCAN.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
Nasties in his last name.
Nasty Ucan or the first letters of his last name.
Right.
Nasty.
Timofey nasty.
You can,
did you see that fight?
No.
Play the stoppage.
Play the uh,
the knockout,
the far,
far right one?
No,
the far right.
That one right there.
Ooh.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Just play right there.
There you go.
This dude is a,
this Russian cats,
a beast,
man.
He,
he was very seasoned in their,
like really relentless with his pressure and super confident in his power and he
stunned Alvarez a couple times in that fight.
I was pretty shocked.
I think there are a lot of guys that aren't in the UFC that are capable of
fighting in the UFC.
That's what I'm saying.
So like definitely there,
there's um,
all,
uh,
I get to see a lot of those guys at those shows are in Russia.
See,
I'm watching this cat and this is not like a freak knockout or something like
that.
This guy's got real smart,
technical striking and he's also puts tremendous pressure on and he's also got
big power and they're amateur combat sports.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
like,
you know,
combat sambo and things like that.
They get a lot of experience.
Yeah.
Well,
when you see a guy like Khabib number,
could Madoff just run through people in the UFC and you know where that guy's
from.
You got to go,
well how many more of those guys were over there,
you know?
Yeah.
The Dagestan crew then that's that beat too.
He's from Dagestan isn't Islam mocket Chavez need from that,
that part of the world as well.
Yeah.
That's where a Keller's areas,
boom,
boom.
That's it.
Yeah.
So I mean the caucus friends,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a warrior.
We your group
of PTA.
Yeah.
There's a lot of man,
so I get to go there.
A lot of them.
I mean it's really exciting.
I get to see a lot of really cool stuff.
Dagestan like okay.
Dagestan was a blast.
Dagestan was fun,
man.
Yeah,
I went there.
Um,
I um,
uh,
you know,
it was there with a,
who was also at the show.
They brought over,
um,
we're doing and uh,
and those guys weren't working for doing it and Anderson Silva's,
those guys are watching fights you missed,
you know,
but I was working.
But yeah,
they took us around.
They showed us a lot of really cool stuff.
I went to like a school where some kids wrestling school,
cause like a lot of uh,
schools that were uh,
athletic.
Uh,
what an athletic orientation and seeing these little kids may put this little
kid up on a bar and had him doing pull ups.
Man,
he was doing pull ups.
I mean he's a little kid,
little bitty kid.
I mean it must have been at least 15 pull ups.
And then,
I mean,
he was a little kid,
like not as like something like nine or something like that.
If and when coach,
when the coach pulled him off,
he was mad.
You could see these meds.
Like,
man,
I got more,
you know what the meeting was mad like,
well there's so that people would,
I could do,
but um,
and the crowd,
they loved him in May so much.
They were like,
it was like,
you know what it was like,
it was like you were watched those videos of like,
um,
the Beatles.
You know what I mean?
When all the people going crazy,
but it's not teenage girls.
It's like a bunch of Harlow wrestlers packs.
Like,
yeah,
I've got the pictures,
uh,
from somewhere.
Yeah.
I can sell them too.
Wow.
So it's that popular over there.
Yeah,
that's it.
Now,
what did
you see the video of,
of those dudes when Cubbie be Connor and they're shooting machine guns into the
air or,
I didn't see that,
but I saw the,
uh,
one of my friends from that area sent me some pictures that she was out on the
street.
She sent some pictures,
uh,
to,
to my wife of them.
Uh,
some video of guys,
uh,
like death she can get and horse racing had horses,
their horses down.
Yes.
Some video that was like,
oh,
shooting guns.
Like those,
yeah.
There are people where it was like a prayer.
People who were so excited about that know that's some energy there.
Yeah.
Imagine you're from a place that many parts of the world never heard of until
now.
I don't know.
W W w how much I thought about Dagestan before it could be you came around and
then now they have the,
not just a world champion,
but the guy who smashed the most famous fighter on the planet.
Right.
One of the most famous fighters on the planet.
It's like him and Floyd Mayweather.
They're probably the two most famous fighters.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It could be just ran through them.
So like he's a,
he's a huge,
huge star over there.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah,
he's cute.
So the,
that uh,
yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a fun place to go.
Matter of fact.
I,
yeah,
I've got to see a lot of cool stuff or your lists.
Dagestan explosive delight after Khabib defeats Mcgregor,
they're all going crazy with their hats on.
I get people out in the street cheering.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah man.
Connors,
all the shit talk leading up to that fight,
man.
Did that backfire like some people at works and then some people it's just,
it doesn't work at all and it just makes him more relentless when Colby was
hitting them going,
let's talk now.
Come on,
Now with him,
you know,
cause he talks the whole time right from the beginning of the eight he starts
talking to he does.
No,
yeah,
he starts talking.
Really?
What does he say?
W and then you hear it when he was fighting Johnson give up.
Give Up.
Yeah.
You know,
I need to tell it a shot.
Give Up.
Then he got him in that horrific Kamora I was watching that Kamora I was like,
don't you just fucking tap.
Come on man.
Tap.
Ah,
ah,
just feeling everything going.
Pop,
snap,
pop.
They didn't want to tap man Johnson.
A tough guy.
Yeah.
But I,
I,
you know that,
uh,
the smack talk,
I mean,
that's what
Tyler does.
Yeah.
But this was a different level.
Let's talk.
He said,
come on,
let's talk now.
Can we hear it?
He has Megan Johnson.
Yeah.
He sounds like he really cares about each other.
You know this,
I deserve it.
I have to fight for the title.
You know this,
I deserve it.
As he's beating him.
Right?
Yeah.
And he's talking to someone on the sideline.
I smash your boy,
Mike.
The scary thing that he ever said was a about Connor.
I want to change his face.
Like,
who want to change his face?
oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
So I heard he's retired,
right?
Connor,
you don't buy it,
right?
I don't know.
Yeah.
If you had to guess.
He's fighting yet.
Han's Mollin camp,
you know,
Han's from monster pictures sparring with Connor today.
Awesome.
Connor's training.
Yeah,
no monsters.
Yeah.
It works from monster.
He's,
he's training.
He's gonna fight.
He's probably just fucking with people,
you know.
I mean,
Connor is a master showman.
In terms of like how to keep people interested in him.
And I just think he just,
he got way out of the line with all this Khabib stuff.
But I'd like to wait.
I would like to wait.
He takes his losses.
Oh,
he took it.
Well,
I liked the way,
I like the way he goes out there and talk smack,
whatever.
When I think I like as a,
I'm in a,
like from a sports psychology point of view,
I think he's a,
he think he's developed there,
you know?
Yeah.
But I don't think the way to get in another fight we could be is to continue to
talk shit after he smashes.
You mean he doesn't have any reason to,
you can just talk shit like he,
he didn't just win.
He smashed and tapped you like it was,
it was only like one or two moments in the fire.
We're,
Connor was taking control with some of the striking and the stand up,
you know,
and that's another choke.
That's another misunderstood choke.
That fulcrum choke there can be.
Got Connor went.
That is a legit net crank.
Yeah.
And people that don't think,
oh,
he tap to that.
Like you attach that to and if you didn't,
you're stupid.
And people were like,
yeah,
because the chin was down there right there.
Like you,
there's a lot when you're,
there's a lot of,
it generates a lot of forced yeah.
Unhinge your jaw and face apart.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That,
that's a legit,
that's a legit submission.
Yeah.
Especially with that.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Back the back of your forum against the guys back as leveraged,
you know,
which caused that fulcrum.
Yeah.
That's horrific.
Very powerful.
It hurts bad man.
There's a lot of those net crank,
so just like,
oh,
you watch people and you just go,
please tap.
Yeah.
There it is right there.
Like you see with Khabib's left arm pressing against the back of Connor and then
also yanking on that and that is ripping his fucking neck apartment.
Yeah.
You never,
yeah.
You until you felt one.
Yeah.
Um,
but Connor,
it's interesting that the ways posted up like that.
Are you just trying to get up and he's getting cracked at the same time?
Yeah.
You got to kind of,
yeah,
he was already,
he had already been smashed by then too.
You know,
he'd been hitting with hit with so many big punches from the top.
He takes a great shot though,
I'll tell you that.
Yeah.
But it's just one of those things where I think in order for him to really have
a real chance at getting another shot,
what he's got to do is beat somebody big and say something that makes Khabib
considerate,
you know?
But not in,
not in the way of what he's been doing in terms of,
you know,
talking shit about him and talking smack.
I mean,
I think the only way it's going to be public demand,
like he's gonna have to get to a position where people want to see him fight,
could be began to see that the result may be different this time.
And then maybe if he could just fucking communicate something to them.
So,
you know,
I respect you,
all trash.
Talk aside,
you know,
I'd like to test myself against you one more time and I think I earned it.
I think that's the only way he's going to get it.
I think if the only way it's going to get it is to,
to win a couple of fights,
beat some real big name guys and then make it so that's,
uh,
something that could be,
is actually interested in.
Well,
okay.
So I don't know if that's the only way,
but it's the way that would be,
uh,
that I would like to see they already offered it to,
could be even keel.
It could be you've said fuck off.
Yeah.
But like that path that you're talking about sounds like a one,
that one that fits good for me.
Yeah.
I'd like to see it that way.
Do you think that trash talking in MMA has gone too far or do you want to get
high?
I mean,
well,
I think it's entertaining.
Yeah.
Uh,
for some people I think it's not,
well here it's hard.
Well,
because
it's not,
um,
it's not always what I want to see.
And it's not,
uh,
I don't know.
It's not the type of person I am,
but not everyone's going to be me.
That's not what,
that's what makes the world go round.
And it's a lot of people want to see it.
And also sometimes it does bring some energy and some you don't.
When it's well done,
it does bring some energy and some excitement to the fight and to the sport.
And at the same time,
not every fight.
What's in wedding was really interesting and was really excited about the UFC,
is that there's a lot of fights that people want to see that have no bearing on
the title.
Right.
And so there's something to that fights that just people want to see.
And I think trash talk sometimes makes fight that people want to see.
Yeah,
for sure.
it makes sense.
Emotional,
it makes things intense.
It's great for selling things.
It's great for selling paper views.
But the question is like,
is it good for the sport overall and should it be something that we encourage?
Well,
how was that for,
and that's the thing is how do we decide what's good for the sport?
Or in what way?
Right.
How do we decide?
Is it good for the way the sport,
uh,
do want the sport to look at as far as martial arts and be in a respectful thing
and people looking at us like that,
maybe not.
Is it good for the sport or the growth of the sport and for more opportunities
for athletes and for our athletes to become,
uh,
names that,
that draw attention from other people that normally didn't know about it.
I Dunno.
I Dunno either,
but yeah,
so,
so I don't know.
I,
I'm torn.
I like both.
I like exactly what it Machita type character that's very respectful bowels and
never talks trash and fights like a,
you know,
just a world caliber martial
artist.
And I also liked that guy talks mad shit.
Think it's funny.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
I enjoy it.
It's like,
I like press conferences for that very reason where,
you know,
guys are talking shit to each other and they're looking over at each other on
the podium.
You know,
it's funny.
Oh,
come on.
If some of them,
yeah,
some of it is hilarious.
Yeah.
How about Connor?
When Jeremy Stevens slit him for Pfizer.
Who the fuck is that guy?
No,
it was effective.
We look,
what do you get to?
When he got up,
he was like,
okay,
I don't have time to insult everyone,
so let's,
yeah,
let's get them all in one place.
Right.
That was great.
Like so it everyone,
would this be efficient?
Come on.
There's comedy,
but what he was talking about where it's red panties night.
Yeah.
That was made it baby.
We got caught up with Greg or play.
He's a fucking character.
My uncle.
Mine isn't that weird situation though where he really never has to fight again.
So you've got to wonder what his motivation is.
You know,
like he has $100 million.
He has a gigantic whiskey company that proper 12 is murdering it.
That that place is killing it.
That that company is,
they're,
they're moving into other countries now.
I mean they're killing it.
He doesn't have to do a thing ever financially.
Right.
Unless he wants to eat diamond sandwiches.
He's basically could do whatever the fuck he wants for the rest of his life and
just live off interest.
But he still likes to fight.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean that's what brought him into the QB.
He fight.
He didn't have to fight Khabib,
but just,
you know,
how much does he want it?
I mean does he want it the same way a guy like style bender wants it or guy like
Calvin Calvin Gaslin wants it and also I think that part of one unit is
different to maybe maybe there's maybe people might want things on their terms
too,
uncertain terms of way you could get in his way.
Like it's like some people were like,
oh,
you'll want it.
I'm wondering any way I can get it.
Some people might want it and say,
well now I want it this way.
Well he was going to fight cowboy.
That was a fight that they were,
they were basically trying to make,
but it was going to have to be a co main event.
And because of that,
I think Connor was not interested in anymore.
He wanted it to be a main event,
you know,
and I'm like Jesus,
like is that really what kept us from controversy is cowboy.
Can you guys a hundred versus cowboy make that a fucking main event.
Like make some malarkey title come up with some hundred 60 pound title or some
shit.
Just come on man.
I do it.
I mean they give out these interim titles left and right.
How about you come up with some alarm excited when that was going to happen?
Yeah.
I was excited to see it.
165 pound malarkey title just come off man.
Conor versus cowboy for the title.
Make a title up but that does make it,
yeah,
I agree.
I don't think it would hurt at all,
but apparently Dana says it makes a big difference in the amount of paper views.
Yeah.
But now that they've already ESPN plus,
is it really going to be,
I mean how does that work now you you,
you pay every month and then you pay a little more for the paper views.
Is that what it is?
Is how it works?
How much more is it?
It's like fights,
just like $5 last,
remember,
whatever it is that you're paying
your monthly.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's a good deal.
If you're into watching all those fights on ESPN plus it is nice.
They do have a great library,
but so does fight pass,
right?
Where does that put five pounds at five past?
I can't see some of the stuff that's on bypass.
There's this other,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Way More.
There's of this door boy tie organisations and yeah,
five passes.
Awesome.
For the gym.
I have a little home gym with the apple TV on it and I always have fipass on
kickboxing.
You watch obscure Moy Thai fights like right from the arena and Thailand,
you know,
it's,
it's really cool.
Like a hundred pound guys beating the shit out of each other and submission
wrestling too.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A lot of Abu Dhabi stuff is on there.
All Eddie Bravo stuff is on there.
All the Eddie Bravo,
invitational combat Jujitsu's on there.
Yeah.
Jujitsu's in a great place right now too,
right?
I mean it's,
there's so many different martial arts that are really at the pinnacle right
now.
I mean,
I think this is such an amazing time for a person yet so many people martial
arts and yeah.
Is A,
this is a great time for martial arts.
Well,
you remember when you and I first got into it,
there was,
I mean there was nothing,
nothing what it is now.
Nothing.
Marshall has been around for thousands and thousands of years and the level of
martial arts since 1993 to today is,
it's indescribably more powerful today.
Like the,
the athletes are so much better.
The fighters are so much more well rounded.
Even in Jujitsu,
if you go back to and watch old Jitsu matches from like 93 and of course you're
going to have like your Hixon Gracie's,
he can Machado's and John Chalk Machado's who are at that elite level,
even back then where they can hang with guys today.
But overall the game is like Saul complaint and also even just the athleticism.
You've seen it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean these dues are some animals.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's incredible.
And I mean,
and really what's interesting to me is that you're really only seeing a small
percentage of the elite athletes that are available in North America that even
decide to get into it,
right.
If you talk about how many elite athletes decide to go into baseball or NFL or
NBA versus how many elite athletes go in the cage fighting,
it's not even close.
Right.
Right,
right.
But it's starting to get some of them slowly,
a little bit,
and some of them are starting to get an inch and in Jujitsu is a reason why some
of them are getting an interest in Jujitsu.
They train,
right?
Like,
yeah.
For Cross training and doing it for something which people want to learn it,
you know,
I mean,
if you're a big guy,
but just know how to fight,
that's gotta suck big old giant guy.
It doesn't actually know how to fight like,
fuck man,
but it learned some of this shit.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
it's just for,
for those big athletes,
the really big pay days or at NFL and that's the other thing too,
is that a lot of those guys are bigger than 265 pounds.
Exactly.
Like they would have to cut a lot of weight to make two 65,
which is isn't
that weird that we have a heavyweight division that you have to weigh in for?
Yeah,
no,
I think that is interesting,
but
I wonder what,
uh,
the super heavyweight division would look like.
It would probably be just a small handful of giant guys.
It would probably be like the flyweights right.
In terms of like how fee,
unless Iceland,
they get those Iceland's strong men dudes.
They start fighting MMA.
Have you seen,
oh,
what's his name?
The Polish a [inaudible] Yap.
Puts.
He fights a lot now.
I like him and you know what,
I've man,
you know,
when people were all were kind of,
giving him a hard time about it.
But man,
Pooja,
I have a lot of respect for him.
Man Fights hard.
He brought a lot of,
put a lot of eyes on our sport who denounced the,
I'm a,
I'm a fan.
He's still thinks he's gotten way better.
He's gotten better.
And he never liked any chumps no.
And he brings it in and there he is.
Look at him.
Look at the size of that.
Motherfucker's still even can look it.
He looks skillful now.
He'd like,
he's moving much better.
And here's the thing,
this phase guys can better got balls of steel.
He fought me.
Tim Silvia,
my referee.
Tapulous yeah,
I was like,
I could not believe that that's where they put him up against for a who is early
in his career.
Like that's what I'm saying.
Fuck the risk.
But that's what I'm like,
I'm respect like were there,
I was like,
I respect you.
You chose him.
Yeah.
It was ridiculous.
And he trows chose him very early in his career.
Rarely.
He really didn't have the skills that he has now.
And Tim is a world champion and the end,
the end,
the type of body that's very hard for punching Nazis.
Oh yeah.
Long and tall.
Long them to wrestler.
Who can put his hands on your hips and control your levers and really make you,
you know,
your muscles get fatigued.
You make you gas out starting from the beginning.
So you could see what it was like early for them getting me,
Tim just start beating the shit out of him once he got tired.
But it's interesting because Tim has the opposite of puts,
now's his body,
right?
Like he doesn't have the best genetics,
just tough.
And people will think that that,
that Pooja set up is going to be,
but actually for,
it's a very hard to fight somebody like Tim.
No,
very hard.
Very hard.
But he's also got massive experience with on,
I mean he's fought literally everybody,
any good all over the world.
Any offshore and yeah,
I mean he fought,
he fought the greats.
He fought Andre Arlovski win our loss.
He was straight up murderer in our last,
he was in his prime.
Randy coture.
You know when Frank Mir broke his arm and he tried to keep fighting,
that's you too,
right?
Yeah.
Cause I remember the crowd was booing like,
Ooh,
I was like,
guys,
you need to look at this.
Yeah,
no,
that's a,
that's,
let me,
I will tell you about that because that was a fun story.
Cause like they,
um,
I hadn't really,
there's one of the first times I think they had trusted me with a championship
and uh,
he,
you know,
the arm broke.
I heard it,
I saw it.
And uh,
I remember,
you know,
I learned a lot.
I learned a lot about my job right then because I,
what I did is I backed off and I let the doctor come in and examine them.
Cause like,
you know,
sometimes when you're dealing with an expert,
you don't want to cloud the way you're supposed to get out of the way.
Right?
Like you don't go to the mechanic and tell them what to do.
So I had,
my mind was thinking like that about the doctor.
And so of course he comes in and she doesn't know what she's,
what she saw.
So he misguides guides her and says,
I think he's worried about this.
And then she's like,
hey,
no,
nothing's wrong.
And I was like,
oh man.
In my mind I was thinking is it was,
it's been great being here,
but I'm not going to be doing this anymore.
You know what I mean?
And then
he agreed that switch already and I swear I was like,
in my mind I was thinking that I was thinking about how to get out of there and
when they start throwing stuff,
oh,
the military camp and maybe you remember they were over there wrestling with the
Samoan security guard is trying to get in there and keep people going and people
are screaming,
yeah,
here it is.
That's his other,
his other break.
It was an awful one.
Yeah.
So that,
I was thinking about that.
And then uh,
you know,
but then you found it,
you saved me.
I was thinking that my retribution was going to be like some kid on the Internet
two weeks later.
Like I found out his arm was broken,
but you found the spot.
And so then that was watching the replay and I was like,
let's take a look at this.
Hold on.
What's that on his arm.
I'm like,
that's a broken arm that Barb is broken.
Look at that.
Watch it one more time.
Oh and I had the truck roll about and then it went into the octagon and I
remember saying immediately like,
you guys need to watch this.
Like here we go.
Let's play this.
Here we go.
That's a broken arm.
So I'm going to thank you for that right there.
Cause I don't have a career path would've been different.
It was one of those things where I felt an obligation to not just interview the
fighter but to explain to the entire crowd like you gotta listen,
this is a,
I know it looked crazy.
Look crazy to me too.
This is a broken arm.
Like this guy's fucked right now.
Three places.
And Tim,
thank you afterwards for saving his career because he said if you didn't stop
that fight and that became a compound fracture.
Fuck man.
Horrible things happen when the bone breaks through the skin.
Yeah,
it happened.
I saw him afterwards and I said,
men,
did you know your arm was broken?
And he told me,
he goes,
yeah,
I know what was in,
what was your plan?
Where are you trying to continue?
So I knew I had a minute before.
The pain really becomes crippling here is and watch this part.
Right.
Snap right there.
I mean that is 100% a double double break.
Yeah.
Both parts of the both bones of the forum snapped in half and it's an unusual
break because of where it is.
Yeah.
It just shows you how fucking strong frank mirs armbars and how long the empty
is.
It was also weird as hell.
His arm went back into place.
How young and muscular I talked to the doctor.
They say that happens sometimes with athletes.
The muscles just put it.
Yeah.
Well he had a plate put in there forever.
It's still in there.
Look at me.
Young,
fresh face.
Joe Rogan and that was kind of young.
Frank looks,
that's crazy.
He looks so lean and young and he's a big old giant dude now.
He was a fantastic commentator.
Yeah,
no,
he's a really good comment.
Really good commentator.
I'm amazed that no one's snatched him up to do commentary.
You know it's funny,
he was working for Aca.
Yeah,
he just stopped though.
He was,
he was there.
He was there for a while in his commentary.
What's weird is he always,
he's as a commentary when I like listening to him,
his commentary and also just talking to him,
he always comes up at an angle that I never think of and it makes sense.
It's worth here and you're like,
oh.
He's like,
what's frank going to say about this?
Sometimes.
Yeah,
he gets some rear dangles.
Very smart dude.
Very well read dude.
Really misunderstood guy and a lot of ways.
But Frank was,
I think it was one of the Lesnar fight when he fought Lesnar either before the
first fight or the second fight,
I forget which fight it was.
He said he wanted lesson to be the first death inside the inside of the cage and
the UFC.
I was like,
what the fuck are you saying?
And then they pulled him out of the commentary for saying that and he's like,
look,
I'm just talking up a fight.
And that was it.
He was doing w e c at that point,
remember?
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Did.
He was really good,
man.
I remember listening to his commentary.
I'm like this guy,
he's,
I,
I'm a big fan of former fighters doing it.
I think they do the best commentary.
He does great comedy a lot.
Yeah.
Daniel [inaudible].
Daniel Cormier is fantastic.
It's really good.
Dominic,
you know who else I like?
Um,
I like Dan Hardee,
Dan Hardee's excellent.
Very,
very.
He's actually kind of morphed into,
I mean he really is as solid as anyone as in including myself is like is doing
like professional commentary.
It's as good as anybody when we're talking about that too.
Oh,
Felder's good Tom mechanics that won that fight.
That's where I learned definitely that when the doctor with the dealer that they
don't know what we all take for granted,
that it's the arm.
So that was kind of my fall further up.
Now I definitely always tell them,
look,
this is actually what happened.
This is what I'm worried about.
This particular part,
you know?
Oh yeah,
that's gotta be huge for you because like,
if a woman gets into the octagon or a man and they,
they don't know anything about the sport,
they're just there because they're a doctor.
Right.
That would have no idea what the fuck.
And I didn't,
I didn't even,
I know,
it seems like that should be the first thing I thought about,
but yeah,
I did a long ass time ago,
Bro.
Yeah.
How many fights do you think you've called out of thousands,
man.
Thousands.
He has a lot.
Dan Townsend.
I'm not crazy.
If you really stop and think about all of that experience,
do you,
um,
do you do seminars for young up and coming rapper?
Do I just did it this weekend?
Yeah,
we're at in Pasadena.
Oh.
So,
uh,
you know,
you can go on my web site,
[inaudible] dot com also,
you can follow me at herb dean MMA on Instagram.
I'll usually do stuff.
I'm on Instagram page when they're posted the picture.
You with the blowtorch.
How?
Okay.
All right,
cool.
I'm worried to see this explosion of followers,
right?
It's coming baby and covers coming blows you.
Yeah,
no,
I,
so I do it.
Uh,
it's,
it's a fight.
I just did it.
It's a,
it's a cool thing because I like doing it because it makes me better every time.
It makes me have to think about things as I look at,
uh,
that.
So we spent three days doing it.
So think about teaching anything,
right?
Yeah.
It makes me,
uh,
makes me a lot better and I always dread it when I'm,
when I'm going to do it because sometimes it just add a dread doing it and then
I haven't finished the holdup part.
The other part I don't like is I have to say no because I have,
it's for certificate and the certificate,
uh,
is what you need a certificate to get licensed.
And so,
um,
some people aren't going to achieve the certificate so they can come in,
you know,
take the seminar,
but there is screening,
right?
Yeah.
So the first day they,
uh,
they,
we,
uh,
we go over a bunch of stuff,
then they teach me some technique and you know what I mean?
And so we can understand that they understand what's going on in there.
And so as far as for judging how to evaluate what these guys are actually doing,
and then that's where I say they teach you technique.
Like they'll see you,
you'll say to them,
hey,
show me how to set up a song.
Go like I go to the,
so we,
we do it in,
um,
we did it in Pasadena.
So I do it at,
at the,
at the courtyard Marriott right there.
We've got a classroom.
Then I can walk two blocks down and take one block to the right and be a
Savannah,
a savant in Young's a fight academy.
Go right there.
Step straight onto the math.
We do a warm up where we get to see a lot of stuff.
Okay.
Yeah.
Show me arm drag.
So many of this,
we get a lot of information right?
Then we can have a few notes.
All right.
Yeah,
show me a pass.
I mean,
that's,
I mean that and then I have them.
Yeah,
teach me a triangle.
Teach me by the numbers.
Teach me,
you know,
as it was taught to you or like,
and I don't care if he learned it on the Internet,
but why do you like it and would maybe,
what do you do different to make it work for you?
And just talk me through it.
Give me as much information as I can.
One guy this weekend took my course and he gave me so much.
If I,
man,
I couldn't wait every time it was gone.
It was really good.
He was a really detailed instructor,
but he was really good.
Then the,
but I learned a lot.
I've got a lot information from some of the other people who I thought was going
to be good because in the beginning we tell why we're here.
It sounded like I had a high level class.
A lot of them weren't.
Um,
they didn't know much about,
uh,
they didn't know enough about position and submission.
How many guys do you think want to be referees but have no experience in martial
arts?
Well,
I think there is a lot.
I think it's common,
you know,
I'm on my website.
It lets people know like,
Hey,
a physical demonstration of a MMA technique is,
is required to achieve certification.
You can come out and you know,
take the seminar if that's fun for you,
which is cool.
My hat's off to you.
You know,
because of the lessons a lot,
you can do it your weekend,
but if you want the certificate,
you need to understand the techniques at a level that you know,
the teach.
Yeah.
At a detailed level and up because you'd have to not understand the details to
make it successful.
And that's why you have to,
if you're going to evaluate it as a judge,
you know,
you have to know why it wasn't successful and you're going to have to be able to
talk it through why you gave credit to something or didn't give credit to
something.
So this is for judging and referee judging and referee.
So the first day I do a,
as the judging and then the judges,
the referees,
uh,
for my,
the way I do my certificate,
if you want to be a referee,
you have to be able to judge also because everyone assumes that you can and
they'll throw you in the judge's seat.
So all in terms of training,
Oh,
if you like to do a small show or something like that,
we'll try and do that.
Yeah.
A small show.
We used to have this thing where Eddie Bravo used to a score.
The fights in between rounds.
It was excellent.
And what was good about it is,
um,
Eddie would break it down on a piece of paper.
He would have like a right calm and a left calm like right column would be you
left column B Jamie and then he would write,
okay.
Terp took him down three times.
Herb almost got a,
an Armbar herb landed five lave kicks.
Jamie cried a lot.
That's what it would say.
No,
you know what I'm saying?
It would say,
and then he would add it up and he would say,
this is why I think he won the round.
This guy had better position,
but this guy landed the big shots.
This guy got hurt,
but he almost got caught in a submission.
So I gave it real close,
but I gave it 10,
nine to this guy.
So you'd get a better understanding like how Howard Letterman used to do.
Harold Letterman used to do it further by saying like,
so that's one of the things like we don't really have in our sport,
like,
uh,
you know,
our,
the way we score around,
we didn't really score it cause we don't,
we don't have like a rubric where we're given a sign value for techniques as
they happen.
So we don't,
that's not what we're doing.
And also,
and,
but I think that's a good idea for training.
It's hard to do it the way Eddie does that,
uh,
lived,
went around because who can write all of that?
What,
I'll take your eyes off for a second.
Right,
right.
And you take your eyes off just for one second.
You missed,
you might miss something that was huge,
you know,
and so I'm,
so that's why a lot of,
uh,
commissions,
you know,
I think Eddie,
what he did was he had like,
he wrote kicks punches.
He has a sort of shorthand system,
I guess.
Right?
Exes,
the sides.
Every time someone took something down and put a little X.
And I encourage people to do that.
And so that's what I do.
Like I,
I,
you know,
well I tell them,
I show them other,
like different people have different systems of shorthand to take some notes
because,
uh,
in the back you want to,
you're going to want to have some notes,
especially when,
um,
when the matches are done,
you know,
this,
they'd say there's a split decision or there's a split round,
there's an outside judge.
Um,
everybody's going to be getting their,
their,
a game to get to their reasonings why they gave it that.
Oh wait.
So that's a,
you're going to have to be able to talk about.
So that's a good way of a scoring around is preparing yourself to be able to
talk about what you actually saw,
what happened and context to the scoring criteria.
That's awesome.
And then this certificate is from you.
Is that how it works?
Well,
just cause from me,
but recognized by certain organizations that are going to make it so that you
can get a job.
So it's from me and here in the United States is registered and recognized by
the Association of Boxing Commissions.
And if you're going to apply to,
let's say Cammo here in California,
uh,
you're going to have to have a certificate of training before you apply it to
the amateur or before you apply it to,
let's say the boxing commission out in Tennessee to a athletic commission out
there or the athletic commission in Nevada.
They're only going to hire people who have taken a course.
That's a recognize that John does one as well.
Um,
a couple of other people do them.
That's excellent.
Yeah.
Big Johns is
coming up in June that will fight week.
Weekend does a big one.
June 6th and seventh.
I just did my,
um,
June 6th and seventh were out.
Do you know where in Nevada and so,
yeah,
if you look for is a it for social media is a UFC card that weekend.
Yeah.
It's a sway.
Does it then?
Yeah.
I'm just given,
given,
given a plug to my competition,
but it's okay.
It's okay to the end of the day,
we want people to get some good training and get information.
Well,
big John is not competition anymore.
Now he's a commentator.
Yeah.
But for my training from a guy,
he's never as competition as a referee.
I mean,
yeah,
we were trying to do it,
but as far as for my course,
I'm want to take my course,
but if they're not going to take mine,
I don't want him to take his,
no,
he's,
he's awesome too.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
that's a few,
a few guys that I get very excited when I see that they're refereeing a big
fight of my career.
Okay.
And I'll pick John.
Definitely big John.
I know.
Yeah.
I've always felt very comfortable.
Damn.
He's been in there from the very beginning.
From the beginning.
I mean there is not a person alive that has more old school credibility than big
John and more high level fights.
Oh yeah,
man.
Yeah.
And he's seen it all the good,
the bad.
You remember Marillo Bustamante versus um,
Matt Lindland.
Oh yeah,
he,
he had a tap him twice.
I think John stopped it and then Matt Lindland complained that they let them
fight again and like,
oh,
you're going to go bring up of,
yeah.
I agree.
Good luck though that,
oh,
what about the other one to right?
A Conan and uh,
oh yeah,
someone Raba in Jan.
Yeah.
The Japanese made them fight again on the same night.
What in the fuck is that ever happen?
We're going to happen again.
And that was for a punch to stopped from a punch.
Right.
He dropped down,
grabbed a hold of the ankle coin,
like he fell,
but that's the way soccer shoots.
He shoots like this.
It looks like he,
you know,
like he's going out.
Yeah.
And then caught Conan and an arm bar in the second fight.
The second time they fought that night,
that night.
And that was like crazy.
We couldn't believe a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu blackbelt could get tapped,
but like what,
what?
And Sakuraba who's smaller than him.
Right.
And then we realize who soccer rabo soccer.
Robin was.
He to me really carried the flag of catch wrestling.
Then Karl gotch style of of submission holds you more so than probably anybody
else.
Oh,
you ever fought in MMA?
Yeah,
definitely.
His style was all Camorra's and armbars.
Yeah.
Remember when he used to tape his legs up?
It looked like the guy could barely walk.
Man.
How the fuck was he fighting?
So good.
His legs would be mama five.
And he's doing submission wrestling now.
Right.
He's fighting he fighting quintet,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
He fought the,
his crew,
uh,
fought Eddie Bravo was crew.
He friend Richie tapped him.
My friend Richard Martinez.
Boogeyman.
Yeah.
Okay.
He got him in a lot for these bad mother fucker about to deal with it.
Unless you're 100% full time grappler and boogies got nasty dark chokes economy
that Doris and he's got that all that break dance.
Yes.
His flexibility
and his,
uh,
his dexterity is ridiculous.
I feel like,
you know,
there's some people you say,
okay,
he's good.
Then there's some people you look at it,
so like I've never got to,
you know,
roll with him,
but he looks like one of those people that like,
you don't know what it feels like until you feel it getting me.
Yeah.
He's a very strong,
yeah.
His brother is two CIOs very strong too,
but then they came from that dancing background where they just have the ability
to manipulate their bodies.
So on you,
it's almost like a gymnast,
you know?
Right,
right,
exactly.
But maybe even more so because they'll like do a lot of stuff where they're
standing on one arm and bouncing around in the Lotus position on one arm in arm
handstand with their legs criss crossed up in the air and they're bouncing
around.
It makes you want to give up.
No need for me to do this.
I can't get yoga,
man.
You'd get,
you're going to be amazed if you keep with it,
how much dexterity improves and your balance approves and everything.
But we were talking about it before the podcast started that it's so good for
your old injuries,
especially that hot yoga.
It's,
I'm a,
I mean,
you know,
I'm,
I'm probably a little bit annoying right now.
I'm like a little Bikram Yoga evangelist.
You're
Brazilian Jujitsu,
blue belts been born again.
I love,
you know,
I've,
I'm guilty as charged.
I do that shit all the time.
I think that with everything I liked though,
get annoying.
It's fun.
I get,
I've been doing it in other countries too.
So like really when I don't take,
when I take those breaks,
that's what gets me,
you know,
derails me.
So I'm like,
you know,
I'm gonna do the extra work,
find a place when I get there.
So I got to go do it in Prague and Warsaw and don't want Saint Petersburg and
there's a little different flavor,
you know what I mean?
So it's cool.
That's dope.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan.
I like to do it on the road to,
mostly I do it at home,
but it's just,
it also that strain of that 90 minutes,
I think it's like meditative.
There's music,
you're just in the poses for 90 minutes.
It's cleansing.
It releases your,
the,
all the bullshit you hold on to in your brain.
It just,
yeah,
no it does.
Yeah.
Sweeps that out the door.
No,
it helps with all of that.
Herb Dean,
we've been talking for three hours.
Oh really?
You believe that shit?
Wow.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you know what actually it's kind of cool because we hang out with each other
a lot,
but this is the first time we got to talk for three hours.
I know,
right?
When we see each other for years.
Yeah.
Every time we talked dinner together or hang out at the fights,
it's like brief conversation brief.
It's at the airport.
You know what I mean?
Spunk.
Piss that you're not going to be in Atlanta this weekend man.
Yeah,
Dan.
Oh yeah.
No.
What the fuck,
how does that work?
Like how do you know like when you do and don't get,
sometimes they call me and you know there's some athletic commissions.
I know we're going to call me.
I Atlanta.
I thought it would be one of those that,
cause I've usually done it when they've been there.
I've done it.
How often did they tell you in advance and they don't tell me that.
Sometimes they tell me far,
sometimes not so far.
So some commissioners,
they,
you know,
they get them on board.
Like I got about,
uh,
the Minnesota,
pretty early.
He reached out,
he was aggressive about getting me on there and he was like,
man,
I really appreciate that.
I figured like,
yeah,
the men make,
wants to make sure I'm there.
This Brazil show that's coming up.
Cristiana the commission.
He reached out to me a long time ago.
Beautiful and said,
hey man,
I'm going to make sure you're at this on card.
Uh,
the Brazil car.
Let me see who is on that car.
Let's look that up.
Okay,
let's see who was on that card.
I think there's a,
there's some good fights there isn't Aldo fight on that card?
He's got like a big fight on that card.
Okay.
All those in a comeback search right now after knocking out natto mercado.
I mean,
that was gigantic.
It might not be labeled yet.
Sometimes like the UFC doesn't put it up on its website.
You know the,
the,
they don't put it up.
What's that?
Oh,
row.
Is that Jessica and drudge?
Ooh.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that girl's a little pit bull.
Jessica and drudge is terrifying.
Do you see that knockout of Carlina?
Kovacevich
yeah,
she came owed her.
Would that overhand right?
Jesus Anderson Silva.
Jared Canon near Holy Shit.
Although that's right.
Fall Canal Ski.
That's a fucking fight.
Aldo and Alexander Volkan ops keep poking off.
Ski is a fucking Juggernaut.
Little Nog still throwing down all these years later against Ryan Span Tiago
Alvarez against star Poli.
I don't know that gentleman.
Okay,
man.
Oh,
PJ Penn versus Clegg.
We'd,
Oh
damn.
Okay.
All right.
That's a good card,
man.
What day is that,
Jamie?
Oh,
Shit.
Might have to have a fight companion.
We haven't had a fight companion forever.
A couple of herb.
You should sit in on one of those.
If you're in town,
man,
I would love to.
They're the best.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
People get ridiculously hammered.
And if Eddie Bravo starts throwing around conspiracy theories,
you've got to check your watch.
Right,
right,
right.
I am looking at the time,
drink some beers and stuff like
May 11th yeah,
I'm open right now.
Make it happen.
But I'll be there.
You'll be there all you will be there.
I found out ahead of time.
That's what it sounds like.
Yeah.
Brazilian one.
Okay.
We'll get you in for one of these.
We should get good cause let's,
most of the time it's not the four of us.
Most of the time it's like two or three and so we always have room for others.
You're a bad mother fucker.
I appreciate you always cool.
Hang with you dean,
Ladies and gentlemen and tell people how they can find you on Twitter and
Instagram.
Herb Dean MMA on everything and everything.
Herb team.com her by not,
of course,
Herb Dean Ladies Gentlemen.